glass and concrete and stone it is just a house not a home sure i'm here with will selman who is a urban planner and are you an architect too uh urban planner urban planner um and uh he has written a book on dub psychology and urban planning which is kind of a funny that he found us because they're uh we i don't know i don't say that i don't want to say we're the only blog but i haven't seen a whole lot of people interested in infusing the study of jung and architecture but we'd written a little bit about that so we're excited to have him he has a new book um teninnitus am i saying that right temenos that's correct okay my greek is a little rusty that's greek right mine is non-existent but okay i know that it's uh it it's a term derived from ancient greece um imagine the plaza in front
玻璃、混凝土和石头，那只是房子，不是家。当然，我和城市规划师威尔·塞尔曼在一起，你也是建筑师吗？呃，城市规划师，城市规划师。他写了一本关于荣格心理学和城市规划的书，他能找到我们很有趣，因为我不知道该怎么说，我不想说我们是唯一的博客，但我没见过多少人对将荣格研究与建筑学融合感兴趣，但我们确实写过一点相关内容，所以我们很高兴能邀请到他。他有一本新书，呃，Temenos，我读对了吗？Temenos，没错。好的，我的希腊语有点生疏了，那是希腊语对吧？我的希腊语根本不存在，但好吧，我知道这是一个源自古希腊的术语……想象一下古神庙前的广场。
of an ancient temple that is while a temple was built on sacred ground, the Temenos basically extends that sacred space out into the city. So that's what a Temenos is. So the sacred space that spills out from the interior of the temple. Yeah, it's that protected holy space. So would that be kind of like a liminal space that it's a fusion of our world and another one overlapping just like an Irish thin place or something that it's part of the city, but also part of the temple? Yeah. And the idea of the book is that both in our civilizational, the point in which we find ourselves in history, as well as urbanistically, we need to start thinking of the entire city in those terms, not just a special place reserved, but take as much care and respect for the city as we always have for nature.
那是古神庙的一部分，虽然神庙建在神圣的土地上，但Temenos基本上将那种神圣空间延伸到了城市中。这就是Temenos的含义。所以它是从神庙内部溢出的神圣空间。是的，那是受保护的神圣空间。那么，这是否有点像一种阈限空间，它是我们世界与另一个世界的融合，就像爱尔兰的“薄弱之地”（thin place）或其他什么东西，它既是城市的一部分，也是神庙的一部分？是的。这本书的理念是，无论是在我们的文明进程中，还是在城市规划方面，我们都需要开始以这种方式思考整个城市，不仅仅是保留一个特殊的地方，而是要像我们一直对待自然那样，对城市给予同样的关怀和尊重。
It sounds like what you're saying is that the city should be viewed as not just kind of a utilitarian or practical thing but uh a fusion of the practical and the spiritual you know that we should be mindful and and view it as an extension of ourselves yeah and we can see the results of not having done so um for uh probably 500 years of this long, slow decline since the advent of science, really. And just a whole complete shift in the fundamentals from which we operate has changed the places we build, not just as we think. And that's a theme that runs through the entire book is that the places we build reflect the values we hold. And that's not working anymore. Those values don't operate well anymore.
听起来你的意思是，城市不应该仅仅被视为一种功利或实用的东西，而应该是实用与精神的融合。你知道，我们应该保持正念，并将其视为我们自身的延伸。是的，我们可以看到过去500年来没有这样做所带来的后果，自从科学出现以来，这是一种漫长而缓慢的衰退。我们运作的基本原则发生了彻底的转变，这改变了我们建造的地方，而不仅仅是我们思考的方式。这也是贯穿全书的一个主题，即我们建造的地方反映了我们持有的价值观。而这已经不再奏效了。那些价值观不再能很好地运作了。
I wonder, I don't know if you had seen the last blog article video that would put out, but it's funny what you're saying. Like one of them was about the design of furniture and specifically mid-century modern furniture. And the other one was about architecture, what Frank Lloyd Wright's process was, that he wasn't quite a classicist, wasn't quite a modernist. But the argument in it is that we used to think of these things as something that was intentional and beautiful and meant to last and a part of ourself and kind of a spiritual thing. And then at some point it just became this practical necessity that we throw it away. And that was to our detriment. You know, even if we have more stuff, even if we have more ability to hoard, it meant that we meant less. And what you had just said, the stuff that we, I forget exactly what the,
我不知道你是否看过我们发布的上一篇博客文章视频，但你所说的很有趣。其中一篇是关于家具设计的，特别是中世纪现代家具。另一篇是关于建筑的，关于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的创作过程，他既不是古典主义者，也不是现代主义者。但其中的论点是，我们过去认为这些东西是有意图的、美丽的、旨在持久的，是我们自身的一部分，是一种精神层面的东西。然后在某个时刻，它变成了一种我们随手丢弃的实用必需品。这对我们是有害的。你知道，即使我们拥有更多的东西，即使我们有更多的囤积能力，这也意味着我们的意义变少了。而你刚才所说的，那些我们……我忘了确切的……
I need to rewind. But the last line that you said is almost exactly the title of the article, except with the word chair, because it was, um, you may address the chair, how, where we sit tells us where we stand. Yeah. The places we build reflect the values we hold. Um, and like you're saying, this is an odd combination of subjects to try and tackle and i have not until the book was completely written and i had sent it off to a publisher
我需要倒带一下。但你说的最后一句几乎就是那篇文章的标题，除了把“椅子”这个词换掉，因为它是……你可能会谈到椅子，我们坐的地方告诉了我们所处的位置。是的，我们建造的地方反映了我们持有的价值观。就像你说的，这是一个试图解决的奇怪的主题组合，直到书完全写完并寄给出版商之前，我都没有……
did i come up with a good 30 second elevator speech for what this is all about uh and it's more like 45 seconds instead of 30 but i think intuitives don't always know what they're writing until it's done you know like you kind of know you need to write it and then later you back up whereas that's the you know the the more sensing and thinking types do not operate that way they have a blueprint and a plan and then they execute and a lot of times intuitives feel called to create this thing and then later you can be like oh wow that's what i was doing okay yeah i did see this thing assembled itself and i was just a tool very much i could i could see that as it happened i was led in various directions that really had
我想出一个好的30秒电梯演讲来概括这本书的内容。呃，它更像是45秒而不是30秒，但我认为直觉型的人在完成之前并不总是知道自己在写什么。你知道，你只是觉得你需要写它，然后事后你再回过头来看。而那些感知型和思考型的人不是这样运作的，他们有蓝图和计划，然后执行。很多时候，直觉型的人感到被召唤去创造这个东西，然后事后你会说：“哦，哇，原来我做的是这个。”好的，是的，我确实看到这个东西自己组装起来了，我只是一个工具。我确实能看到它是如何发生的，我被引导向不同的方向，这些方向真的……
no connection but they all resolved in the end and And right up front, I state there's a most urban designers, urban planners, I hope, know of a book called The Art of Building Cities by Camillo Sitton. He was writing in the 1880s. And he was lamenting the fact that things were not going well back in the 1880s he thought that there were serious problems in in what he was seeing in the way that uh he was uh from vienna i believe um and in that book fairly close to the beginning, he says something like this. We can no longer build a beautiful work of art way a city is designed, operates, it's just a symptom of a much, much larger problem that we're experiencing now and have for hundreds of years. We've gotten to a breaking point and there has to be some sort of a shift, not in the way we design. We'll keep designing in all sorts of secondary ways until we gain some sort of larger vision of what it means to be human.
没有任何联系，但它们最终都解决了。在书的开头，我提到大多数城市设计师、城市规划师，我希望，都知道卡米洛·西特写的《城市建设的艺术》这本书。他写于19世纪80年代。他当时在哀叹19世纪80年代的情况并不乐观，他认为他所看到的城市设计方式存在严重问题。他来自维也纳，我相信。在那本书的开头附近，他说了一些类似这样的话：我们再也无法建造美丽的艺术品了。城市的设计和运作方式，只是我们现在正在经历的、并且已经持续了数百年的一个更大得多的问题的症状。我们已经到了一个临界点，必须发生某种转变，而不是在我们设计的方式上。只要我们还没有获得关于“作为人类意味着什么”的某种更宏大的愿景，我们就会继续以各种次要的方式进行设计。
Well, and I think that that's always a work in progress right you know trying to figure out who we are what we are um but we're not even trying anymore you know we've kind of given and that's what's sad i mean so i'm kind of i butt heads with people um because you know i'm i do depth psychology and yungi and stuff and so there's some people who are you know very practical they take that in their evo psych and you know dna archetypes and whatever and then there's other people that are kind of new age spiritual but you lose the psychology of it it's just kind of too woo woo and well i guess everything that i won't think at any point is true and this crystal will cure my scrofula and you know it's it becomes too unscientific you know what you're saying that so you should be spiritual, it's like, you know, people kind of laugh because it's a trope about like Marie Kondo, you know, basically Jung's idea of ensoulment, you know, that we should have Martin Buber, the mystic Martin Buber who wrote I Am Now, and that you should have a very personal, it should be something that you know i love this chair because it is beautiful and it matches this thing and i love this because
嗯，我认为这总是一个正在进行的过程，你知道，试图弄清楚我们是谁，我们是什么。但我们甚至不再尝试了，你知道，我们已经放弃了。这就是令人悲哀的地方。我的意思是，我和人们意见不合，因为我从事深度心理学和荣格研究之类的东西。有些人非常务实，他们接受进化心理学、DNA原型等等；还有一些人是新时代灵性主义者，但你失去了其中的心理学成分，它变得太“虚无缥缈”了。好吧，我想我不会认为任何一点是真实的，比如“这块水晶能治好我的腺病”之类的，它变得太不科学了。你知道你所说的，所以你应该有灵性，人们会笑，因为这是一个关于近藤麻理惠的陈词滥调，你知道，基本上是荣格的“灵魂注入”理念。你知道，我们应该有马丁·布伯，那位写了《我与你》的神秘主义者，你应该有一种非常个人的联系。它应该是你知道的，“我喜欢这把椅子，因为它很美，它和这个东西很配，我喜欢这个，因为……”
you know something that you think about and um like so when you're talking about a lot of people kind of make fun that marie frondeau saying you know hold each thing in your house and say does this spark joy and if it doesn't spark joy throw it away you know there's something that you know you are happier when you have less stuff you You are happier when you're more intentional, but also the kind of the spiritual component of this stuff can be kind of grating or overdone. And so something like the Parthenon, you know, that's an attempt to find a culture of what this group of people is, the ancient Greeks. And yeah, it's beautiful and it's held the test of time and influenced, you know, so
你知道，你思考的东西。就像当你在谈论很多人嘲笑近藤麻理惠说“拿着你家里的每件东西，问它是否能激发快乐，如果不能，就把它扔掉”时，你知道，当你拥有的东西更少时，你会更快乐。当你更有意图时，你会更快乐。但这些东西的精神成分也可能让人感到刺耳或过度。所以像帕台农神庙这样的东西，那是试图寻找这群人——古希腊人——的文化。是的，它很美，经受住了时间的考验，并影响了……
much stuff. But also, you know, it's kind of propaganda, right? You know, like the Persians are coming, and you're getting kind of nervous about the scary stuff in the East. And so they, you know, it's a huge expense. It wasn't like they just had the money lying around. They chose to do this, you know, basically to control the population and to give it a vision of self.
很多东西。但同时，你知道，它也是一种宣传，对吧？你知道，波斯人要来了，你对东方那些可怕的东西感到有点紧张。所以他们，你知道，这是一笔巨大的开支。并不是说他们只是手头有钱。他们选择这样做，你知道，基本上是为了控制人口并给他们一个自我愿景。
And so a lot of them, we're not going to go through the whole Parthenon, but the biggest motif there is this, you know, ordered civilization overcoming a barbaric chaotic enemy, you know, and their war against the Amazons is what is, you know, on the outside of it. And then, you know, the Titans overthrowing the gods at certain, or the gods overthrowing the Titans and creating this new order. But it's very much what they were trying to give the people
所以很多，我们不会讲完整个帕台农神庙，但那里最大的主题是这个，你知道，有序的文明战胜了野蛮、混乱的敌人。你知道，他们与亚马逊人的战争就是刻在它外面的东西。然后，你知道，泰坦推翻了神，或者神推翻了泰坦并建立了这种新秩序。但这非常符合他们试图给人民的东西……
a vision of who they were because it was a time of crisis. The Peloponnesian War is dragging on a little bit long. There's some plagues going on. The climate is changing. We're not really sure if we're going to be in charge of all this stuff anymore. We had all these great ideas but now the blank edges of the map are getting filled in and oh, there's other philosophies.
一个关于他们是谁的愿景，因为那是一个危机的时代。伯罗奔尼撒战争拖得有点久了。发生了一些瘟疫。气候正在变化。我们不再确定我们是否还能掌控所有这些事情。我们曾经有所有这些伟大的想法，但现在地图上的空白边缘正在被填满，哦，还有其他的哲学。
We're not the only camp in town anymore right right and and it's an attempt you know so it is gorgeous and this attempt to provide a spiritual blueprint of this is who we are this is our identity but it's also kind of propaganda by the people being like yeah come on look this is who we are you know so you know both of the practical and the spiritual are part of these things. Yeah, and it's, you mentioned the sort of tension between, you know, traditional Jungian thinking and the side of it that goes a little bit more on the woo-woo, touchy-feely side. And I sort of touch on that a little bit. So the first, the book is divided up into four sections. In the first section,
我们不再是城里唯一的阵营了，对吧？对，对。这是一种尝试，你知道，所以它很华丽，这种尝试提供了一个精神蓝图，即“这就是我们，这就是我们的身份”，但它也是一种宣传，人们会说：“是的，来吧，看，这就是我们。”所以，你知道，实用和精神都是这些事物的一部分。是的，你提到了传统荣格思想与那些稍微有点“虚无缥缈”、感性的一面之间的那种张力。我确实稍微触及了这一点。所以，这本书分为四个部分。在第一部分，
I focus really on an attempt, maybe just for myself, to explain what it is, what is my personal vision. Because a lot of your biography is in the book too. I mean, you talk about concept relevant to architecture and design, but then you talk about how you dealt with that concept personally, you know, in your life. Oh yeah. I was raised for several years as a small child in Paris. And so I got the opportunity to have that experience of walking down particular streets embedded in me very early. And then after that I grew up for a number of years on a small beach cottage on Chesapeake Bay, isolated by salt marshes. So the most intense urbanism and complete wild untamed nature back to back and so that that has
我真的专注于一种尝试，也许只是为了我自己，去解释它是什么，我的个人愿景是什么。因为你的很多传记也在书中。我的意思是，你谈到了与建筑和设计相关的概念，但随后你谈到了你在个人生活中是如何处理这些概念的。哦，是的。我小时候在巴黎住了几年。所以我很早就有了那种走在特定街道上的体验。在那之后，我在切萨皮克湾的一个小海滩小屋里长大，被盐沼隔绝。所以最强烈的城市主义和完全野性的自然紧随其后，所以这……
given me a particular um understanding i think that is that i find very valuable but that sort of speaks in a way to the the tension that i see between spirituality and religion. In the spiritual world these days, not just in the secular world, but the spiritual community generally, the new age world, there seems to be just an absolute total lack of respect for religion. Religion is false, it's fake, it's a front, but I'm spiritual. I've got the real thing. Which is, of course, what every cult leader says. Right, right. It's a great tool in the way that you can manipulate control for better or worse. I think that there are, that can be helpful and useful. You just better make sure you've got the right leader.
给了我一种特殊的理解，我认为这非常有价值。但这在某种程度上说明了我所看到的灵性与宗教之间的张力。在当今的灵性世界中，不仅仅是在世俗世界，而是在整个灵性社区，新时代世界，似乎对宗教完全缺乏尊重。宗教是虚假的，是伪造的，是一个幌子，但我有灵性。我有真正的东西。这当然是每个邪教领袖都会说的话。对，对。这是一种很好的工具，你可以用它来操纵控制，无论好坏。我认为，这可以是有帮助和有用的。你只是最好确保你有正确的领导者。
I think you look for the people who have a monopoly. That becomes the problem is when I just have to, I really want you to have this great thing. It's just, you know, I'm really the only one that can do it. It's the only way that's going to work. Everything else is. And after 50,000 years. I'm going to hire you when you hear that.
我认为你寻找的是那些拥有垄断权的人。问题在于，当我不得不……我真的希望你拥有这个伟大的东西。只是，你知道，我真的是唯一能做到这一点的人。这是唯一行得通的方法。其他一切都是。在5万年之后。当你听到这个时，我会雇佣你。
None of the other things work. It's the only thing. Yeah, for $1,500 a session, I'll take care of you. Yeah. But we've been at this for, you know, depending on the source material that you choose. There's an archaeologist, anthropologist named von Petzinger, and she has done just amazing work on cave art specifically. And her understanding is that a sort of a great awakening took place in the evolution of the species. A couple of points, roughly 200,000 years ago, and I think that's right.
其他东西都不起作用。这是唯一的东西。是的，每次1500美元，我会照顾你。是的。但我们已经这样做了，你知道，取决于你选择的原始资料。有一位名叫冯·佩辛格的考古学家、人类学家，她在洞穴艺术方面做了非常了不起的工作。她的理解是，在物种进化过程中发生了一次大觉醒。大约在20万年前的几个点，我想那是对的。
Check me on that and then again about 50,000 years ago humans started being involved in activities that had no practical purpose talking about like the Venus of Elendorf and the Venus figurines those all those sorts of things art in in general, music started to appear, things that weren't practical necessities of life, but apparently were really, really important to our ancient ancestors. And so there is I, I imagine that this is the memory that we have of, um, the source material for the garden of Adam and Eve. You know, when we woke up at some point in history, um, enough consciousness developed in us out of our animal instinct. And we looked around and said, oh my God, what am I?
核实一下，然后大约在5万年前，人类开始参与没有实际目的的活动。谈论像维伦多夫的维纳斯和维纳斯小雕像，所有这些东西，艺术，总的来说，音乐开始出现，那些不是生活中的实际必需品，但显然对我们的古代祖先来说非常、非常重要。所以我，我想象这就是我们拥有的记忆，关于亚当和夏娃花园的原始资料。你知道，当我们历史上的某个时刻醒来时，足够的意识从我们的动物本能中发展出来。我们环顾四周说：“天哪，我是什么？”
What's going on? What am I supposed to be doing? And the whole story of mythology, religion, poetry, ritual is a process over the past 50,000 years and more of figuring out that question, who we are, what we're meant to be doing here. And the idea of the book is to imagine the city is the classroom in which that exploration can take place. Because the natural world, that's been our home since forever. But more and more, the world is urbanizing. I don't have that daily experience with wild nature, but I do have a daily experience with concrete
发生了什么？我应该在做什么？神话、宗教、诗歌、仪式的整个故事，是过去5万多年来弄清楚那个问题——我们是谁，我们在这里注定要做什么——的过程。这本书的理念是把城市想象成可以进行这种探索的教室。因为自然世界，那是我们永远的家。但世界越来越城市化。我没有那种与野性自然的日常体验，但我确实有与混凝土的日常体验……
and asphalt and buildings and so forth um how can we infuse those settings with the same sort of intentionality and do it on a conscious intentional level at this point so that's what that's what i'm trying to get at so um i mean i think that does a pretty good job of explaining how are you, what is urban planning, what do you do, and then what is kind of Jungian depth psychology, and what do those have to do with each other?
和沥青和建筑物等等。我们如何才能在此时此地以一种有意识的、有意图的层面将那种意图注入这些环境中？所以这就是我想要达到的目标。所以，嗯，我的意思是，我认为这很好地解释了你是谁，什么是城市规划，你做什么，然后什么是荣格深度心理学，它们之间有什么关系？
That probably gives the audience a good primer of, without being super specific about what an urban planner does, how is somebody operating with the lens of depth psychology, what that is, and then how those two things could could inform each other um you know how much have you ever seen adam curtis's documentaries like all watched over by machines of love and grace any of those i don't know that name at all it's interesting um they're very loose
这可能给观众提供了一个很好的入门，在不超级具体地说明城市规划师做什么的情况下，说明一个以深度心理学视角运作的人是什么样的，那是什么，然后这两件事如何相互告知。你知道你有没有看过亚当·柯蒂斯的纪录片，比如《爱与恩典的机器守护着一切》之类的？我根本不知道那个名字。这很有趣，它们非常松散……
the thesis is very loose and implied you know there's no over there's never like oh we set out to discover this and then but we what we found was even more you know it's very just like weird clips of culture and this overlapping of anthropology design philosophy um psychology and and the way that those kind of inform each other but you know how much of the destruction of what you're saying you know that intentionality being taken out comes from i don't even hesitate to even say where it comes from but you have culture that kind of moved everything away to like a consumed experience that was the smallest part of what we do or the least of what we do it's like okay i live in a house that i hate so and i won't buy the stuff that i want so that
论点非常松散且隐含，你知道，没有……从来没有像“我们着手发现这个，然后我们发现的是……”之类的。它只是非常奇怪的文化片段，以及人类学、设计哲学、心理学之间的这种重叠，以及它们如何相互告知。但你知道，你所说的那种破坏，那种意图被剥离，有多少来自于……我甚至不敢说它来自哪里，但你有那种把一切都转移到“消费体验”的文化，那是我们所做之事的最小部分，或者最少的部分。就像，“好吧，我住在一个我讨厌的房子里，所以我不会买我想要的东西，这样……”
i can go on a cruise or you know i'll go into an office that I spend 90 percent of my time and that's awful because I want to be able to afford to go on vacation to this other place. That's nice. You know that I'll be in for this teeny tiny fraction of my life. But it's almost like the point of life became not a routine, not what we do from 90 percent of our time. You know, in this strange way, it became about these experiences elsewhere. Yeah, it's like we we we have such low expectations of our immediate surroundings um and there's there's such a um disparity between what we see every day and what we can find as advertised in a beautiful cruise to little seaside towns on the coast of Italy or something like that. Our ancestors did things so much better than we did.
“我就可以去游轮旅行”，或者“我会去一个我花90%时间待的办公室，那很糟糕，因为我想有钱去度假到另一个地方。”那很好。你知道，我一生中只有极小的一部分时间会待在那里。但几乎就像生活的意义不再是例行公事，不再是我们90%时间所做的事情。你知道，以这种奇怪的方式，它变成了关于这些在别处的体验。是的，就像我们对周围环境的期望太低了，而且我们每天看到的和我们在美丽的游轮上、在意大利海岸的小海滨城镇等地方看到的广告之间存在着巨大的差距。我们的祖先做得比我们好得多。
And it's because of the things that we hold as being more important. What would you say that is now? What is the thing that we hold to be more important than our our self, our intentionality our soul, what's the altar? well in a two different directions to go with that, one is very
这是因为我们认为更重要的东西。你会说现在那是什么？我们认为比我们自己、我们的意图、我们的灵魂更重要的东西是什么？祭坛是什么？嗯，有两个不同的方向，一个是……
specific and I'll say it's the car the car gives you freedom right, you can go anywhere because I've got a car um but we spend so much time and effort making sure that the car gets everything it needs so we can go anywhere that we don't create a plan to go there's no place to go as a part of annual you know expenditure by families and it's probably about the same you know poorer people drive a cheaper car but it's
具体的，我会说是汽车。汽车给了你自由，对吧？你可以去任何地方，因为我有车。但我们花费了太多的时间和精力确保汽车得到它需要的一切，这样我们就可以去任何地方，以至于我们没有制定计划去那里。没有地方可去。作为家庭年度支出的一部分，你知道，这可能差不多。你知道，较穷的人开较便宜的车，但它是……
the same percentage of income as the richer person driving the nicer car. But it becomes this thing that you have to have. I think the I saw somewhere that car ownership is equivalent to a $50,000 a year mortgage. You want a nicer house, get rid of one of your cars. I'm car free now. I had a three hour a day commute for several years. Um, and every year I got rear ended at a stoplight. And the last time was by a drunk driver doing 45 miles an hour. Three cars were totaled. One guy was, uh, in rehab for two years. Um, and I decided not to replace the car. My intention in moving back here to Washington, DC was to be car free.
收入的百分比和开好车的富人是一样的。但它变成了你必须拥有的东西。我想我在某处看到，拥有汽车相当于每年5万美元的抵押贷款。你想要一个更好的房子，摆脱你的一辆车。我现在不买车了。我有几年每天通勤三个小时。而且每年我都在红绿灯处被追尾。最后一次是一个酒驾司机以每小时45英里的速度撞的。三辆车报废了。一个人在康复中心待了两年。我决定不再换车。我搬回华盛顿特区的初衷就是不买车。
It's the Metro, my bicycle, my feet. And if I need to, I can rent a zip car. So we've created a mindset of mobility to the point where we've completely forgotten that, you forgotten that there ought to be a place to go to. That's part of a larger story that I guess Jung would speak to. And that's basically the transition from a, I don't know what the traditional mindset to the modern scientific mindset, which basically arose. And what, 15, 1600s, basically, when science started to take over. And you can sort of see this in the history of Western civilization as a whole, but alchemy specifically. Alchemy goes back 2,000, 3,000 years, and it was always basically a spiritual practice, an effort to understand the spiritual realm by the processes
那是地铁、我的自行车、我的双脚。如果需要，我可以租一辆Zipcar。所以我们创造了一种流动性的心态，以至于我们完全忘记了，你忘记了应该有一个地方可以去。这是更大故事的一部分，我想荣格会谈到这一点。这基本上是从……我不知道传统的思维方式到现代科学思维方式的转变，它基本上兴起于……什么，15、1600年代，基本上是科学开始接管的时候。你可以在整个西方文明史上看到这一点，但特别是炼金术。炼金术可以追溯到2000、3000年前，它基本上一直是一种精神实践，一种通过……的过程来理解精神领域的努力。
of the physical realm. And somewhere around the 15, 1600s, 1600s definitely, that became the precursor to what we know now as chemistry, a very, very different way of thinking. And you can see the decline of alchemy coinciding with the rise of science. And so now nothing... And just to kind of parse what you're saying for the audience there, you know, if you're not familiar, because even people who like Jung, you know, alchemy famously ended his affair with Tony Wolfe. Jung had him on J-12 for a while. He got to alchemy and it ended. A lot of people have a hard time following Jung there or they don't know what it is. And so basically, you know, you have pre-scientific, you know, evidence based practice.
物理领域。而在1600年代左右，1600年代绝对是，它成为了我们现在所知的化学的前身，一种非常、非常不同的思维方式。你可以看到炼金术的衰落与科学的兴起相吻合。所以现在什么都没有……为了给观众解析你所说的，你知道，如果你不熟悉的话，因为即使是喜欢荣格的人，你知道，炼金术著名地结束了他与托尼·沃尔夫的关系。荣格在J-12上有一段时间。他接触到了炼金术，然后它结束了。很多人很难跟随荣格到那里，或者他们不知道那是什么。所以基本上，你知道，你有前科学的、基于证据的实践。
You have people basically personifying nature. They assume that this stuff works like us, you know, well, the moon's not a planet. This is something about me in relationship to me because I need it. And so the projection of our own psychology into science, basically assuming that, you know, lead would turn into gold and that chemistry and mineral mineralogy would work based on the way our own psyche works, you know, it's, it's this projection so people are kind of telling on themselves so when you look at alchemy there's all this stuff about you take the thing that's not very good but then you purify and this is a gross oversimplification but then
你有人们基本上将自然人格化。他们假设这些东西像我们一样运作，你知道，“嗯，月亮不是行星。这是关于我与我自己的关系，因为我需要它。”所以我们自己心理学向科学的投射，基本上假设，你知道，铅会变成金子，化学和矿物学将基于我们自己心灵运作的方式运作，你知道，这是一种投射，所以人们在某种程度上是在说他们自己。所以当你观察炼金术时，有所有关于你拿走不太好的东西，然后你净化它，这是一种严重的过度简化，但然后……
you purify it and it goes through trials and it gets stronger and it gets harder and then you get the unique good center and the gold is extracted from the chaff and there's this idea of psychological growth and spiritual development that we were sort of assuming science worked like, because that's how we work before we had science. And then chemistry comes and says, actually, these things don't care about you at all. And they have nothing to do with you. You know, there's their neutrons and electrons. And this stuff is just completely random and arbitrary.
你净化它，它经历考验，它变得更强，它变得更硬，然后你得到独特的中心，金子从谷壳中提取出来。有一种心理成长和精神发展的理念，我们假设科学是这样运作的，因为在我们有科学之前，我们就是这样运作的。然后化学来了，说：“实际上，这些东西根本不在乎你。它们与你无关。”你知道，有中子和电子。这些东西完全是随机和随意的。
And you are unimportant. And you've got to memorize all these numbers if you want to do anything, which has a place. And so that's kind of what you're saying, is that we took ourselves out of the world, or we took, you know, our spirituality out of the world a little bit too much, and I don't want to speak for you, but just to clarify people that may not be familiar with some of those terms. No, that's a great summation, and so when you make that sort of transition, you're dropping off, you know, there's 50,000, 200,000 years of human experience that you're starting to ignore for the sake of something that's really what? It's 500 years old, maybe. A very, very dramatic shift in thinking. And science and the technology that grows out of it
而且你是不重要的。如果你想做任何事情，你必须记住所有这些数字，这有它的位置。所以这正是你所说的，我们把自己从世界中抽离出来，或者我们把，你知道，我们的灵性从世界中抽离得太多了，我不想替你说话，但只是为了澄清那些可能不熟悉其中一些术语的人。不，这是一个很好的总结，所以当你进行那种转变时，你正在放弃，你知道，有5万年、20万年的人类经验，你为了某种实际上是什么的东西而开始忽略它？它只有500年历史，也许。一种非常、非常戏剧性的思维转变。科学和从中发展出来的技术……
have done absolute wonders. But it's come to a point where maybe the harm is starting to outweigh the benefit. And what's really interesting is that subatomic physics, particle physics, is getting to the point where it's about as esoteric as any ancient philosophy in the theory there you know the point at which energy transitions to matter and so forth or that something can duly be a particle a wave and an energy that is partly present in this galaxy but also disappearing so maybe it's going another place i mean these are what these i'm not a scientist but this is what theoretical physics is saying which is sort of the best operating assumption we have right now.
创造了绝对的奇迹。但它已经到了一个地步，也许伤害开始超过利益。真正有趣的是，亚原子物理学、粒子物理学正在达到一种地步，它和任何古代哲学一样深奥，其中的理论，你知道，能量转化为物质的点等等，或者某物可以同时是粒子、波和能量，它部分存在于这个星系中，但也正在消失，所以也许它去了另一个地方。我的意思是，这些是……我不是科学家，但这就是理论物理学所说的，这是我们现在拥有的最好的操作假设。
One thing that I think is related to you kind of talking about the spiritual and the scientific is, I'm playing with my webcam here because it's starting to fall, is there's two places where I think another author puts Jung better than he puts himself. Like Jung is trying to say something and then he's not able because he's a pretty brilliant articulate guy one of them is easy to read though no not easy to read um one one is ego and archetype i think edinger when he comes in and says there's two parts of self there's this existential objective thing that is only what we create and then there is this completely subjective you know kind of myopic spiritual oneness you know and they don't know how to be in the same head um that kind of existential the intersection of existentialism and mysticism i think edgar stone rises better than you and the other one is tasty and edge of the sacred he says you know that what yung is saying is that there's these three different
我认为有一件事与你谈论灵性和科学有关，我正在玩我的网络摄像头，因为它开始掉下来了。有两个地方我认为另一位作者比荣格自己更好地表达了荣格的思想。就像荣格试图说些什么，然后他不能，因为他是一个非常聪明、口齿伶俐的人。其中一本很容易读，不，不容易读。嗯，一本是《自我与原型》，我想埃丁格进来时说，自我有两个部分，一个是只有我们创造的这种存在主义的客观事物，然后是这种完全主观的、你知道，近视的精神合一。你知道，他们不知道如何待在同一个头脑里。那种存在主义与神秘主义的交集，我认为埃丁格写得比荣格好。另一个是泰斯和《神圣的边缘》，他说，你知道，荣格所说的是，我们有这三个不同的……
levels to us and we haven't quite culturally and we haven't really gotten to the next one yet but we need it because if we're going to be saved that's the thing that saves us and the first one is just mythology projection we assume that everything is about us and we project our psychology onto the world and we live in this kind of spiritual myopic place and then science is the second one that develops and says no actually none actually, none of this is real. You're totally unimportant. That's all silly. It's not logical and it's not objective. So it's not real.
层次，我们还没有完全在文化上达到下一个层次，但我们需要它，因为如果我们想要被拯救，那就是拯救我们的东西。第一个只是神话投射，我们假设一切都是关于我们的，我们将我们的心理学投射到世界上，我们生活在这种精神近视的地方。然后科学是第二个发展出来的，说：“不，实际上没有……实际上，这些都不是真的。你完全不重要。那都是愚蠢的。它不合逻辑，也不客观。所以它不是真的。”
And science gives us these things, but ultimately it rings kind of hollow when you're trying to build a society based on the assumption that humans are not important or needed or special or, you know, anything, you know,
科学给了我们这些东西，但最终当你试图建立一个基于“人类不重要、不需要或不特别”的假设的社会时，它听起来有点空洞。
and that the third layer that he has, that he kind of wanted you, that he thought that you wanted us to attain was this idea that you have, you do have science that you can operate with an objectivity and a logic, but that you have to be willing to not make that everything and say that there's still an openness to things that we do not understand and a spiritual realm and that there is an openness to uh and it's kind of hard to articulate that the third lens because you know he's saying like science is important we need it but also we're not really existential creatures we're kind of we're beings, and we need to have a relationship with that.
而他拥有的第三层，他认为荣格希望我们达到的，是这种理念：你确实拥有可以以客观性和逻辑运作的科学，但你必须愿意不让它成为一切，并说仍然有一种对我们不理解的事物的开放性，以及一个精神领域，并且有一种对……的开放性。而且很难表达那个第三个镜头，因为你知道，他说科学很重要，我们需要它，但同时我们并不是真正的存在主义生物，我们是……我们是存在，我们需要与那个建立关系。
And one of the ways Jung thought that that would happen was through theoretical physics. He drinks a lot of red did of Pauli and his world clock. And yeah, Jung was very much a shaman in that sense of, in fact, he related his clinical methodology to shamanic or not shamanic, I'm sorry, all chemical processes, seven steps and so forth, five steps. But I think that's what is needed in a civilizational sense right now, that bringing together of those opposites.
荣格认为这会发生的方式之一是通过理论物理学。他喝了很多保利的红酒和他的世界时钟。是的，荣格在那种萨满意义上确实非常像一位萨满，事实上，他将他的临床方法论与萨满或不是萨满，对不起，炼金术过程联系起来，七个步骤等等，五个步骤。但我认为这就是目前文明意义上所需要的，那种对立面的结合。
And so in thinking about cities, our cities look like infrastructure now, because that's what you think of them as. You know, the overhead wiring, the electrical transformers we see on telephone poles, you just think if your house was built that way with wires running across the living room and so forth. No, we hide that sort of thing in conduits behind the walls because it's not attractive. But out in the public realm, we don't think about that at all because it's just stuff. And to bring back that sort of soulful, artistic valuation of place.
所以在思考城市时，我们的城市现在看起来像基础设施，因为你就是这样认为它们的。你知道，架空线路，我们在电线杆上看到的电气变压器，你只是想如果你的房子是那样建造的，电线穿过客厅等等。不，我们把那种东西藏在墙后的导管里，因为它不吸引人。但在公共领域，我们根本不考虑这一点，因为它只是东西。要带回那种灵魂的、艺术的场所价值。
I mean, just the idea that we could bury power lines. You don't have to just be looking at wires and crap and fans. This stuff could just be under the ground if we wanted to spend the money to value that you know more um i think one of the big examples for me is like um where we send our kids to school you know american high schools and middle schools they're built like prisons they're black windowless you know or not maybe not black but they're windowless cinder blocks surrounded by fences and i mean sometimes barbed wire and it's just like what are you teaching your children you know right right right and i i don't know i just i feel like one of the one of the idea that
我的意思是，仅仅是我们本可以埋设电线这个想法。你不必只是看着电线和垃圾和风扇。如果我们想花钱去重视这一点，这些东西本可以埋在地下。你知道，更多……我认为对我来说最大的例子之一是，我们把孩子送到哪里上学。你知道，美国的高中和初中，它们建得像监狱。它们是黑色的、没有窗户的，你知道，或者也许不是黑色的，但它们是无窗的煤渣块，被栅栏包围，我的意思是，有时还有铁丝网。这就像，你在教你的孩子什么？你知道，对，对，对。而且我不知道，我只是觉得其中一个……其中一个理念……
you're talking about is kind of scary to people because i mean when you look at the public sphere like one of the fastest ways to get people to just have this emotional reaction to you and hate you and attack you is if you just say nicely you know um hey could we just dare to maybe imagine that the world could be a little bit better than it is now you know if you just say hey this thing that everyone agrees is really bad and sucks could we maybe just work on it it's like you know you but you see people who just gently say that and it's like left and right and you know people are like oh yeah you're a democratic pedophile or you're a trump mega what i don't know like the guy's just saying that like our life is
你正在谈论的对人们来说有点可怕，因为我的意思是，当你观察公共领域时，让人们对你产生这种情绪反应、恨你并攻击你的最快方法之一，就是如果你只是礼貌地说：“嘿，我们能不能敢于想象世界可以比现在好一点？”你知道，如果你只是说：“嘿，这个每个人都同意真的很糟糕、很烂的东西，我们能不能稍微努力一下？”就像，你知道，你看到人们只是温和地说出来，就像左派和右派，你知道，人们会说：“哦，是的，你是个民主党的恋童癖，或者你是特朗普的MAGA，我不知道。”就像那个人只是说我们的生活……
not great and it's going in a bad direction and maybe we could make a baby step to a thing that was a little bit better i enjoyed enjoyed your interview with Duwane some time ago. He's the only person I've ever seen. I've worked with him on a few occasions. As an urban planning consultant for
并不好，而且正朝着一个糟糕的方向发展，也许我们可以向一个稍微好一点的东西迈出一小步。我很喜欢你前段时间对杜安尼的采访。他是我见过的唯一一个人。我曾与他合作过几次。作为城市规划顾问，
30 years now, I've been in enough public settings where I've been attacked as a communist and a Nazi in the same meeting, which was lots of fun. And then the third political party in America that nobody talks about, or I call them like the radical centrists, you know, it's like the people who they're like, well, the truth always has to be between two bad ideas. And you're like, well, I mean, does it? I mean, this is maybe like, it's like they're too, they don't want to be seen as like extreme or bad or anything. And so they don't stand for anything. And they just have to compromise with whatever. And
30年了，我在足够的公共场合被当作共产主义者和纳粹分子在同一个会议上攻击，这很有趣。然后是美国没有人谈论的第三个政党，或者我称他们为“激进中间派”，你知道，就像那些人，他们说：“嗯，真理总是必须在两个坏主意之间。”你会说：“嗯，我的意思是，是吗？”我的意思是，这也许就像，他们不想被视为极端或坏人或任何东西。所以他们不代表任何东西。他们只是不得不与任何东西妥协。而且……
both of them do it, both kind of parties do it. But you know, you'll just see these things where somebody was like, look, you have to make a decision. Do you want to pull out of the war do you want to do this and there were just a lot of times where obama would be like what if we just send half the amount of troops and do nothing and it's like man like you know or you know and you see you know romney and people do the same thing where it's like they're just too afraid to be like yeah this is the right direction i'm going to go there and i mean that's probably a bigger voter base those being offensive is the worst crime you can commit now I think they're believing in something you know it's yeah but what's interesting I was going to mention Duani he's the only individual I've ever seen um in a public setting to be able to look an audience in the eye and say,
两者都这样做，两个政党都这样做。但你知道，你只会看到这些事情，有人说：“看，你必须做出决定。你想退出战争吗？你想做这个吗？”有很多次奥巴马会说：“如果我们只派出一半的军队，什么都不做呢？”就像，伙计，你知道，或者你看到罗姆尼和人们做同样的事情，就像他们太害怕说：“是的，这是正确的方向，我要去那里。”我的意思是，这可能是更大的选民基础。冒犯别人是现在你能犯下的最严重的罪行。我认为他们相信某事，你知道，这是……是的，但有趣的是，我正要提到杜安尼，他是我见过的唯一一个……在公共场合能够直视观众并说：
what you're doing sucks. This is pathetically bad. And there are so many ways to improve and you're too stupid to do something about it. He will literally use those terms and people love him for it. And I think that's why you get innovators in America kind of have this trickster energy, know like this because they were so um i know we have such a weird relationship to like the messiah complex and you know but like because the culture really likes the status quo doesn't want things to change
“你们正在做的事情很烂。这太糟糕了。有很多方法可以改进，而你们太蠢了，无法对此做点什么。”他会字面上使用这些术语，人们因此而爱他。我认为这就是为什么你在美国看到的创新者有一种“捣蛋鬼”能量，你知道，因为他们太……我知道我们对“弥赛亚情结”有一种奇怪的关系，你知道，但因为文化真的很喜欢现状，不想让事情改变……
you know you somebody could never come in like dwani and say hey you know paris does this and this works better and why don't he has to be like no screw y'all this blows like do that no no but like and um and you get innovators do that i mean i i see that in psychology because i don't think therapy as a whole is in a great place um you know we basically you know over relied on cognitive therapy which meant that, which cognitive therapy is fine for some things, but it meant that we only study therapy that we can turn into a number. And I mean, the therapy modalities that you can turn into an objective number suck. They don't have the intuition of the clinician. They don't have the intuition of the
你知道，某人永远不可能像杜安尼那样进来，说：“嘿，你知道巴黎这样做，这效果更好，为什么不……”他必须说：“不，去你们的，这太烂了，像那样做……”不，不，但像……而且，你让创新者这样做。我的意思是，我在心理学中看到了这一点，因为我不认为治疗作为一个整体处于一个很好的位置。你知道，我们基本上过度依赖认知疗法，这意味着，认知疗法对某些事情很好，但这意味着我们只研究我们可以转化为数字的治疗。我的意思是，你可以转化为客观数字的治疗方式很烂。它们没有临床医生的直觉。它们没有……的直觉。
patient. They don't make room for a relationship, frankly, and they don't treat trauma, you know, because they're only talking about behavior and behavior is the last step in trauma. But you see that in all these fields. These people have to kind of come in with it takes somebody with enough energy to kind of blow something up in order for there to be change. I mean, it doesn't seem like other countries, other cultures work like that. I think we are sort of at the the the cutting tip, the cutting edge. When I think of the long, slow decline of Western civilization, Jung said that the scariest place on Earth was the United States. Yeah.
病人。坦率地说，它们没有为关系留出空间，而且它们不治疗创伤，你知道，因为它们只谈论行为，而行为是创伤的最后一步。但你在所有这些领域都看到了这一点。这些人必须以某种方式带着它进来，需要一个有足够能量的人来炸毁某些东西，以便有改变。我的意思是，其他国家、其他文化似乎不是那样运作的。我认为我们处于……切割的尖端，前沿。当我想到西方文明漫长而缓慢的衰退时，荣格说地球上最可怕的地方是美国。是的。
I think he was scared of it too you know of the us because of our incredibly powerful tools that we have and the naive way we think about them and it was such a new country and such a big country and becoming such a powerful country i mean this other stuff it had gone through these experiments you know early on and the us was just the wild west i mean this other stuff it had gone through these experiments you know early on and the u.s was just the wild west i mean yeah it's like well we actually do this now but it's like giving an ar-15 or whatever they are uh to a 12 year old um you know here's this here's this big thing i can do anything with it but there's's not the life experience and the wisdom to make good use of it. So how do you go about starting to change that? And I don't think that you do.
我想他也很害怕，你知道，害怕我们，因为我们拥有极其强大的工具，而且我们对这些工具的看法又如此天真。那是一个如此崭新的国家，如此庞大的国家，并且正在变得如此强大。我的意思是，其他国家在早期都经历过这些实验，而美国就像是狂野的西部。我的意思是，是的，这就像是——好吧，我们现在确实在做这件事，但这就像把一把AR-15步枪或其他什么东西交给一个12岁的孩子。嗯，你知道，给你这个，给你这个大东西，我可以用它做任何事，但却没有足够的生活经验和智慧来善用它。那么，你打算如何开始改变这种状况呢？我不认为你能做到。
In one sense, I'm pretty pessimistic. You know, it's like when ancient rome started to collapse there was um a real loss of respect for its traditional religions um you know jupiter and minerva yeah yeah yeah they're they're all these ancient gods and but they're they're silly and shallow and they have all these domestic fights amongst themselves and there's just nothing there anymore. And what the Romans would do 2,000 years ago is take pilgrimage to ancient Egypt. Because there, you know, the ancient religion was even older and it was mysterious. There were all sorts of
从某种意义上说，我非常悲观。你知道，这就像古罗马开始崩溃时，人们对传统宗教——你知道，朱庇特和密涅瓦——失去了真正的尊重。是的，是的，是的，它们都是古老的神，但它们很愚蠢、很肤浅，它们之间有各种各样的家庭纠纷，那里已经什么都没有了。而2000年前的罗马人会做的是去古埃及朝圣。因为在那里，你知道，古老的宗教甚至更古老，而且很神秘。有各种各样的
strange rituals and the gods were different and that was somehow respected um because the old was collapsing and the new which eventually became christianity had not yet arrived and i think that's sort of what's happening here now christianity in a sense has run its cycle through history. And it's, I think I would be willing to say it's as great a source of wisdom as the world has ever seen, but we suck the juices out of it. And it has devolved into a cultural dinosaur,
奇怪的仪式，神也不一样，这在某种程度上受到了尊重，因为旧的正在崩溃，而新的——最终变成了基督教——还没有到来。我认为现在这里发生的事情也差不多。基督教在某种意义上已经走完了它的历史周期。而且，我想我愿意说，它是世界上所见过的最伟大的智慧源泉，但我们榨干了它的汁液。它已经退化成了一只文化恐龙，
in a sense. The life has gone out of it, and I think that's kind of a natural cycle. These things never quite die. They put on new clothes, but you have a language you cling to for a while, and it becomes irrelevant, and then you rediscover the same thing with a new language. Different language, different symbols, and so forth, but we're in that in between time and that hasn't happened yet and so we're we're going off in all sorts of odd directions whether it's um new age spirituality
从某种意义上说。它的生命力已经消失了，我认为这是一种自然的循环。这些东西永远不会完全消亡。它们换上了新装，但你有一段时间会紧紧抓住一种语言，它变得无关紧要，然后你又用一种新的语言重新发现了同样的东西。不同的语言，不同的符号，等等，但我们正处于那个过渡时期，而那还没有发生，所以我们正朝着各种奇怪的方向发展，无论是新时代的灵性，
or manga or whatever it is we're looking for anything um until we settle on something new. And my sense is that the city can be a point at which that something new can be the soil in which that something new, that new vision can take hold. And it would be great to prepare for that in some way. By designing a container for souls to come into. Which in the past was what we did. It was a container. We're kind of mixing metaphors here, but the metaphor does work as a
还是漫画，或者其他什么，我们都在寻找任何东西，直到我们确定了某种新的东西。我的感觉是，城市可以成为那个新事物可以落脚的土壤，那个新的愿景可以扎根的地方。如果能以某种方式为此做好准备就太好了。通过为即将到来的灵魂设计一个容器。这在过去是我们所做的。它是一个容器。我们在这里有点混淆了隐喻，但这个隐喻确实起到了
microcosm or macrocosm. You know, Jung saw religion as this thing that sort of contains the unconscious so that you have, until you're ready to hold it, you have something telling you how to live. And then the goal isn't just to be a slave to that forever. The goal is to have it protect you, you know, like a mother protects a child until they're ready to take on more responsibility. And then you start to understand these things with a little bit more nuance and you start to be able to do them but the city sort of does the same thing you know we don't have cities that like protect people we don't have cities that provide a nice space um and i mean i would be surprised if most people in america even know what an urban planner is or that it exists i mean i think we have this kind
微观或宏观的作用。你知道，荣格认为宗教是一种能够容纳无意识的东西，这样在你准备好掌控它之前，你就有某种东西告诉你如何生活。然后，目标不仅仅是永远做它的奴隶。目标是让它保护你，你知道，就像母亲保护孩子直到他们准备好承担更多责任一样。然后你开始以更细致的方式理解这些事情，你开始能够做到它们，但城市也做了同样的事情。你知道，我们没有那种保护人们的城市，我们没有提供良好空间的城市，而且我的意思是，如果大多数美国人甚至不知道什么是城市规划师，或者它是否存在，我会感到惊讶。我的意思是，我认为我们有这种
of libertarian attitude that i buy this box of land and then I build my stuff in that box. And if you want to build something, then you put it here. The idea that there's like a central vision that says like, hey, wouldn't it be nice if there was a park in the middle of the city? Wouldn't it be nice if there were bike paths that cross this so that we don't get people killed by cars, but you can also ride a bike? Wouldn't it be nice if there was a pedestrian walkway that went over here so that you couldn't just walk one street, you can walk across the whole city and you know i don't think people know you know in your in your world they do but i don't think the average person knows that that's something that happened no they're they're often shocked when they walk into the planning office to get a zoning permit
自由意志主义的态度，即我买下这块地，然后我在这个盒子里建造我的东西。如果你想建造什么，你就把它放在这里。那种认为有一个核心愿景的想法，比如，嘿，如果城市中间有一个公园不是很好吗？如果有一些自行车道穿过这里，这样我们就不会让人被车撞死，但你也可以骑自行车，不是很好吗？如果这里有一条人行道，这样你就不能只走一条街，你可以穿过整个城市，不是很好吗？而且你知道，我不认为人们知道，你知道，在你的世界里他们知道，但我不认为普通人知道那是发生过的事情。不，他们走进规划办公室申请分区许可证时，通常会感到震惊。
what do you mean their rules and regulations and then they get angry you know and then getting well and then they get angry and then getting well and then they get angry if somebody takes the next door property and wants to build a coal refinery or something next to them you know if i get to do anything i want then so does he and that doesn't that doesn't accrue to um civilization are you are you familiar with James Hellman, the Jungian analyst and writer? I don't even know if he was a Jungian analyst
你是什么意思，他们的规则和条例？然后他们就生气了，你知道，然后变得——好吧，然后他们就生气了，如果有人拿走隔壁的房产，想在他们旁边建一个煤炭精炼厂什么的，你知道，如果我可以做任何我想做的事，那么他也可以，而这并不能促进文明。你熟悉詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman），那位荣格派分析师和作家吗？我甚至不知道他是否是荣格派分析师，
by the end of his life. What was the name again? James Hellman. Oh, good Lord, I've got him. A lot of this book started after I read City and Soul. But that's pretty much all I read city and soul. So, but that's pretty much. He's interesting to me.
在他生命结束时。名字又是什么？詹姆斯·希尔曼。哦，天哪，我有他的书。这本书的很多内容是在我读了《城市与灵魂》（City and Soul）之后开始的。但那基本上就是我读过的全部，城市与灵魂。所以，但那基本上就是。他对我来说很有趣。
Cause he is like, you take, uh, well, I mean, Hillen's career is interesting. I mean, he,
因为他就像是，你拿，呃，我的意思是，希尔曼的职业生涯很有趣。我的意思是，他，
he's brilliant and he has a lot of really good ideas. And then he also is kind of a crank in a lot of areas and like really loud about it. Um, and you know, he, he like a lot of male, you know,
他很聪明，有很多非常好的想法。然后他在很多领域也算是个怪人，而且对此非常大声。嗯，而且你知道，他，他像很多男性，你知道，
get analyst kind of goes into the woods by the end of his life. Um to me there's always like he was that he was that those are all very american archetypes like he took yung's ideas and brought him to america and kind of got eaten by its own thing i mean there's like he's a little bit of a hustler you know he grew up in atlantic city like here's the people you know calling on the boardwalk, and there's, he's kind of talking about spirituality and union things in that way that, you know, there's something to it, but it's also a little bit of a grift, you know. Yeah, I always got the sense that nothing ever satisfied Hillman. He was never satisfied, and I got the sense it was because he was from one of those early generations right after young. And he felt that he should come up with some grand, some great new thing.
分析师在生命结束时会走进森林。嗯，对我来说，他总是像——他就是那些，那些都是非常典型的美国原型。他采用了荣格的思想，把它们带到了美国，并被它自己的东西吃掉了。我的意思是，他有点像个骗子，你知道，他在大西洋城长大，就像这里的人，你知道，在木板路上叫卖，而且，他以那种方式谈论灵性和荣格的东西，你知道，这其中有一些道理，但它也有一点点欺诈的成分，你知道。是的，我一直觉得没有什么能让希尔曼满足。他从来没有满足过，我感觉这是因为他来自荣格之后的那几代人之一。他觉得他应该提出某种宏大的、伟大的新事物。
And it never quite happened. He's got lots of little gems scattered all around, but they don't ever coalesce into the full-formed. A lot of his books are kind of like J.J. Abrams movies, where it's like line by line, they work shot by shot, and then you back up and you're trying to sit with the argument. It's like, wait a minute, if you're going to shoot the missiles at the Star Trek ship, then why would you put the people in it if you thought that... None of it works. It's just a compelling scene to see these things open, you know, and Hellman kind of writes like that, but when I talk to Leon Krier, it's funny, because I've always been kind of afraid, I've always kind of related to Hellman, and felt like my own worst impulses that i needed to check were ones that he over indulged and you know you you feel that energy when i talked to leon career he was
但这从未真正发生。他有很多散落在各处的小宝石，但它们从未聚合成一个完整的形态。他的很多书有点像J.J.艾布拉姆斯的电影，就像逐行、逐镜头地看，它们确实有效，然后你退后一步，试图去理解那个论点。就像，等一下，如果你要向星际迷航的飞船发射导弹，那你为什么要让人们待在里面，如果你认为……这一切都不起作用。这只是一个引人注目的场景，看到这些东西打开，你知道，希尔曼写东西有点像那样，但当我与莱昂·克里尔（Leon Krier）交谈时，这很有趣，因为我一直有点害怕，我一直有点认同希尔曼，觉得我需要检查的我自己最坏的冲动就是他过度放纵的那些，你知道，当你和莱昂·克里尔交谈时，你会感受到那种能量，他
like oh i met this guy a long time ago in syria it's a lot like you james hillman do you know and told him career told me that hillman said um to him you know america you go to europe and the buildings are supposed to pull your eye upward so that you're always in communication with the divine you're always contemplating heaven and the lines go up and you go into american buildings and we put a drop ceiling and we put fluorescent lights to make you not look up to make you stare down into hell perfect perfect yeah yeah yeah Perfect. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And so there are, you know, with that, it's really hard to find good models here. And the last third of the book, I guess, I focus on where I am now, Washington, D.C. What LaFont did in his design for Washington, D.C. was very much a political and spiritual metaphor.
就像，哦，我很久以前在叙利亚见过这个人，他很像你，詹姆斯·希尔曼，你知道吗？莱昂·克里尔告诉我，希尔曼对他说，嗯，你知道美国，你去欧洲，那些建筑旨在将你的视线向上拉，这样你就能始终与神圣沟通，你始终在沉思天堂，线条向上延伸，而你走进美国的建筑，我们安装了吊顶，我们安装了荧光灯，让你不要抬头，让你盯着地狱看。完美，完美，是的，是的，是的，完美。是的。是的。是的。所以，你知道，有了这些，在这里真的很难找到好的模型。我想书的最后三分之一，我关注的是我现在所在的地方，华盛顿特区。朗方（L'Enfant）在设计华盛顿特区时所做的事情在很大程度上是一个政治和精神的隐喻。
And we don't see that anymore. We don't know about that. And partly that was because LaFont didn't tell people what he was up to. But the whole story of LaFont and the way he designed Washington, he and George Washington very much held a vision of the United States becoming the grand global empire built on ideals. And so the, well, Novus Ordo Seclorum, a new world order.
我们再也看不到了。我们不知道这一点。部分原因是朗方没有告诉人们他在做什么。但朗方和设计华盛顿的方式的整个故事，他和乔治·华盛顿非常坚定地持有美国将成为建立在理想之上的宏伟全球帝国的愿景。所以，嗯，新世界秩序（Novus Ordo Seclorum）。
And so many conspiracy folks now are worried about, you know, this new world order that's coming. Well, it was there from the beginning. That was the whole point. On the top of the Washington Monument washington monument right yeah there it is and well the washington monument has an amazing story by itself um but what lafont was doing he didn't just lay out the streets uh what he started off by doing was creating what i call a trellis. Just like in your backyard, you build a wire trellis so that vines can grow up and life
所以现在很多阴谋论者担心，你知道，这个即将到来的新世界秩序。嗯，它从一开始就在那里。这就是重点。在华盛顿纪念碑的顶部，华盛顿纪念碑，对，就在那里，而且，嗯，华盛顿纪念碑本身就有一个惊人的故事，嗯，但朗方在做什么，他不仅仅是规划街道，呃，他开始做的是创造我所说的格子。就像在你的后院，你建造一个铁丝格子，这样藤蔓就可以长上去，生命
can flourish. He created a geometric trellis out of which the street system grew and the location of buildings were placed. And it was based um on what we now know as sacred geometry which again is sort of getting over there into the woo-woo side of things but they were into that though they didn't see that there yeah we study them but we don't study their assumptions you know right right we we love what they did but we don't respect their their methodology and you're saying that
就可以繁荣。他创造了一个几何格子，街道系统从中生长出来，建筑的位置也被放置在其中。它是基于，嗯，我们现在所知的神圣几何学，这又有点进入了那种“呜呜”（woo-woo）的领域，但他们确实沉迷于此，尽管他们没有那样看待它。是的，我们研究他们，但我们不研究他们的假设，你知道，对，对，我们喜欢他们所做的，但我们不尊重他们的方法论，而你说的是
people don't know that about dc i would argue that design is something that we don't see we feel right and so a ton of people have these emotional reactions to this stuff because it works but you start explaining it to them and they're like no no i didn't know that so that's not why i like dc and it's like so many people that have lived there you say oh i'm going to dc to see my sister or something they're like oh washington Washington live there and then the cherry blossom and you know, it's like they have this relationship to it Because it's different but they don't they don't know it. I mean, it's our capital We don't even know what it looks like you watch movies and they're always like the snipers up there and the Jason Bourne or whatever And they're like Washington DC and they fly over it and it's like New Yorkork or toronto there's like these right right like 73 buildings
人们不知道关于华盛顿特区的这一点。我会争辩说，设计是我们看不见但能感受到的东西，对吧？所以很多人对这些东西有情感反应，因为它是有效的，但你开始向他们解释，他们会说，不，不，我不知道，所以这不是我喜欢华盛顿特区的原因。就像很多住在那里的人，你说，哦，我要去华盛顿看我姐姐什么的，他们会说，哦，华盛顿，住在那里，还有樱花，你知道，就像他们与它有这种关系，因为它与众不同，但他们不知道。我的意思是，它是我们的首都，我们甚至不知道它长什么样。你看电影，他们总是像上面的狙击手，或者杰森·伯恩什么的，他们说华盛顿特区，然后他们飞过它，就像纽约或多伦多，有这些，对，对，像73栋建筑，
and it's like dc is flat like it's it's intentionally like it's not you can't build that it doesn't we don't even know what it looks like you know you're able to substitute this wild stuff in movies and people don't recognize it who who have been there or live there you know i i hear uh tourists on the subway all the time um out, okay, over there's the Capitol. No, that's the White House, the power of the Capitol, symbolically using the meaning behind ancient geometry. So in the ancient world, the number five represented the earth and its people. Can you say a little bit about why that is or what that assumption is? So,
而且就像华盛顿特区是平的，就像它是故意的那样，它不是，你不能那样建造，它不——我们甚至不知道它长什么样，你知道，你能够在电影中替换这些疯狂的东西，而那些去过那里或住在那里的人却认不出来，你知道，我经常在地铁上听到游客，嗯，出去，好的，那边是国会大厦。不，那是白宫，国会大厦的力量，象征性地利用了古代几何学背后的意义。所以在古代世界，数字五代表地球及其人民。你能稍微说说为什么会这样，或者那个假设是什么吗？所以，
in the ancient world, numbers and shapes had meaning. There were certain things ascribed to it. So, for instance, the Jewish flag, the Israeli flag has the six pointed star on it. Those are actually two triangles, one facing up, one facing down, which is essentially meaning the earth reaching up to heaven and the heavens reaching down to earth so those sort of symbols were built in uh everywhere so or even the seal that kind of like a lot of schools and institutions there's that lemon-shaped seal like that and i went to swanee that's the overlap of two spheres
在古代世界，数字和形状是有意义的。有某些东西被归因于它。所以，例如，以色列国旗上有一个六角星。那实际上是两个三角形，一个朝上，一个朝下，这本质上意味着地球向上触及天堂，而天堂向下触及地球，所以这些符号被内置在，呃，到处都是，或者甚至是印章，那种像很多学校和机构都有的那种柠檬形状的印章，像那样，我去过塞瓦尼（Sewanee），那是两个球体的重叠，
right it's like the version of the yin yang symbol it's two circles and and their edges touch each other's center it's called a vetric of piscis it's the reconciliation of opposites um and in fact l'enfant used that um in his uh creating the trellis for Washington. So with the number five representing the earth and its people, the number six represented the gods in heaven, wherever this came from back in Mesopotamia 5,000 years ago. And so what Lafon did, you'll often see people saying the masons were designing secret symbols in the streets of washington the masons were assuming everyone thought that at the time because they
对，它就像阴阳符号的版本，它是两个圆圈，它们的边缘触碰彼此的中心，它被称为“双鱼图”（vesica piscis），它是对立面的和解，嗯，事实上，朗方在创造华盛顿的格子时使用了它。所以，数字五代表地球及其人民，数字六代表天堂里的神，无论这最初来自哪里，5000年前的美索不达米亚。所以朗方所做的是，你经常会看到人们说共济会在华盛顿的街道上设计秘密符号，共济会假设当时每个人都那么想，因为他们
they did all the educated people kind of were operating on that on those yeah what lafont was doing was not some secret masonic and they weren't seen in conflict with christianity like they're like people feel now if you explain it to them. All architects, all artists knew of these principles back then. It was common knowledge. It's only secret now because we dispense with it. We don't believe it. We forgot it, so it's a secret.
他们确实，所有受过教育的人当时都在那种，那些，是的，朗方所做的不是什么秘密的共济会行为，而且他们并不认为这与基督教有冲突，就像人们现在如果向他们解释时感觉到的那样。当时所有的建筑师、所有的艺术家都知道这些原则。这是常识。它现在之所以是秘密，是因为我们摒弃了它。我们不相信它。我们忘记了它，所以它成了一个秘密。
We forgot it, so it's a secret. But the number six is represented by Connecticut and Vermont avenues reaching out from the White House, forming an equilateral triangle above the White House. The number five surrounding the Capitol building, so for instance, Pennsylvania Avenue, Massachusetts Avenue Avenue form the sides of five-sided stars. Locke didn't design the entire star, but parts of them are there. The metaphor is the tension between the gods in heaven, the president, the king, with number six, and the earth and its people at the Capitol building, earth and heaven, how do you reconcile those two intentions? Earthly politics, dirty, crappy methodology, compromises, all that with your heavenly aspirations.
我们忘记了它，所以它成了一个秘密。但数字六由从白宫延伸出来的康涅狄格大道和佛蒙特大道代表，在白宫上方形成一个等边三角形。数字五环绕着国会大厦，所以例如，宾夕法尼亚大道、马萨诸塞大道构成了五角星的边。朗方没有设计整个星星，但部分存在。这个隐喻是天堂里的神（总统、国王，数字六）与地球及其人民（国会大厦，数字五）之间的张力，地球与天堂，你如何调和这两个意图？世俗政治、肮脏、糟糕的方法论、妥协，所有这些与你的天堂愿望。
How do you reconcile those two, both in yourself, your personal life, and as a nation, as a culture, as a civilization? How do you balance those two? That's the metaphor that he built into the city. And it required this new design language because when you had Europe, the king is the king and the nobility or the nobility because they have land and the land that is handed down by god to them
你如何调和这两者，无论是在你自己、你的个人生活中，还是作为一个国家、一种文化、一种文明？你如何平衡这两者？这就是他融入城市的隐喻。它需要这种新的设计语言，因为当你在欧洲时，国王就是国王，贵族就是贵族，因为他们有土地，而土地是上帝传给他们的，
means that they are different from you and that was a pretty easy social order that you have peasants and you have nobles and that's that you know right you're landed you're a person and if you're not you're less than a person and then they the british bring that system to america and then it doesn't work because you have this guy on the other end of the world being like hey i have some land in england so i'm actually better than you and you need to do what i say and george washington i got fields i got a bunch of land who are you get out of here yeah not happening anymore and so there is this the architect you know when he's, the urban planners, you see that in a lot of American architecture. They're like, well, we can't just say, you know, church, castle, and is the architecture anymore.
意味着他们与你不同，那是一个相当简单的社会秩序，你有农民，你有贵族，就是这样，你知道，对，你有土地，你是一个人，如果你没有，你就不是一个人。然后英国人把那个系统带到美国，然后它行不通，因为你在世界的另一端有这个家伙，就像，嘿，我在英国有一些土地，所以我实际上比你好，你需要做我说的。乔治·华盛顿，我有田地，我有一堆土地，你是谁，滚开，是的，不再发生了。所以有这个，建筑师，你知道，当他，城市规划师，你在很多美国建筑中都能看到这一点。他们就像，好吧，我们不能只是说，你知道，教堂、城堡，就是建筑了。
It has to be more for the people. I mean, yes, the president is here and there are, you know, nobles in America. But then how do we make the number six talk to the number five you know how do we make the earth and its people be in communion with and and all of a sudden you get this and i mean it's for lack of a better word it's democratic it's not just like well the church is beautiful everything else is a peon hovel with rats you know it's like you can't that design language fails you know of nobles live in a castle and you live in a thatched hut you know because we how do you so i'm kind of failing to put this succinctly but
它必须更多地为人民服务。我的意思是，是的，总统在这里，美国也有贵族。但我们如何让数字六与数字五对话，你知道，我们如何让地球及其人民与它交流，突然之间你得到了这个，我的意思是，由于缺乏更好的词，它是民主的，它不仅仅是，好吧，教堂很漂亮，其他一切都是带有老鼠的卑微棚屋，你知道，就像你不能，那种设计语言失败了，你知道，贵族住在城堡里，你住在茅草屋里，你知道，因为我们，你怎么，所以我有点没能简洁地表达出来，但
they needed a new language for design and a lot of dc is a struggle to find that well yeah la font one of the reasons that i think he didn't really tell people what he was up to, this was all unknown. There was an Englishman named Nicholas Mann who wrote a book on La Font's design for DC. And he sort of reverse engineered the whole process and discovered what La Font was up to. So La Font didn't tell anybody about this trellis and i think largely because of what you were saying it was very old world it was kind of too highfalutin for america in a sense were much more um leveled and what he was up to was too spiritual and intellectual perhaps for this this newly liberated democratic nation just wasn't thinking in those terms but I think what something that you alluded to earlier,
他们需要一种新的设计语言，而华盛顿特区的很多地方都是寻找这种语言的挣扎。嗯，是的，朗方，我认为他没有真正告诉人们他在做什么的原因之一，这一切都是未知的。有一个叫尼古拉斯·曼（Nicholas Mann）的英国人写了一本关于朗方华盛顿特区设计的书。他以某种方式逆向工程了整个过程，并发现了朗方在做什么。所以朗方没有告诉任何人关于这个格子的事，我认为很大程度上是因为你所说的，它非常古老，对美国来说在某种意义上太高深了，我们更，嗯，平等，而他所做的事情对于这个新解放的民主国家来说太精神和知识化了，也许只是没有用那些术语思考，但我认为你之前提到的某件事，
that sort of the third phase of what we need to do of bringing the two sides back together, it's like with the scientific revolution being this second phase of human experience. It's like being a teenager, in a sense, being a 13-year-old and experimenting. And you've got to rebel against your parents in order to create your own autonomy,
那种我们需要做的第三阶段，即把两边重新结合起来，就像科学革命作为人类经验的第二个阶段。这就像是一个青少年，在某种意义上，是一个13岁的孩子在实验。你必须反抗你的父母才能创造你自己的自主权，
which is sort of intellectually what science has done. We've broken away from the past. But you can't stay in that stage forever. You've got to mature into wholeness eventually. So how do you take what Lafont was trying to do in making the city a metaphor in language and in form that the 21st century scientific community can understand and learn from. So that's what I'm trying to figure out. Well, and I think in the same way in Jungian psychology, the self isn't a destination. It's this process of kind of remembering where you come from but you can't hold everything and then coming back to an ego but still you know keeping in contact with a more spiritual center but when you can't live in you know architecture is kind
这在知识上是科学所做的。我们已经与过去决裂了。但你不能永远停留在那个阶段。你最终必须成熟为完整。那么，你如何将朗方试图在使城市成为语言和形式上的隐喻方面所做的事情，转化为21世纪科学界能够理解和学习的东西。所以这就是我试图弄清楚的。嗯，而且我认为在荣格心理学中也是一样，自我不是一个目的地。它是一种记住你来自哪里的过程，但你不能保持一切，然后回到自我，但仍然，你知道，与一个更精神的中心保持联系，但当你不能生活在，你知道，建筑也是
of that too and in the article i had about frank lloyd right i said what i liked about wright's design that made him i think not just a modernist like frank gary that's throwing out everything i mean i i feel like with frank gary that's throwing out everything i mean i feel like with frank gary you could go to him on different days and ask for the same design and you would get a different structure you know he would wad off a piece of paper differently in autocad um somebody like like right you know you would have even if you wiped his memory he would have designed almost the same structure because this process was pretty consistent he said i want to look at the natural world i want to look at the function of the building how do these people actually live i'm
那样的。在关于弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特（Frank Lloyd Wright）的文章中，我说我喜欢赖特设计的地方，这使他我认为不仅仅是一个像弗兰克·盖里（Frank Gehry）那样的现代主义者，那是抛弃了一切，我的意思是，我觉得弗兰克·盖里，那是抛弃了一切，我的意思是，我觉得弗兰克·盖里，你可以在不同的日子去找他，要求同样的设计，你会得到一个不同的结构，你知道，他会在AutoCAD中以不同的方式揉皱一张纸，嗯，像赖特这样的人，你知道，即使你抹去了他的记忆，他也会设计出几乎相同的结构，因为这个过程相当一致。他说我想看看自然世界，我想看看建筑的功能，这些人实际上是如何生活的，我
going to study what they're doing and then i'm going to look at a greater spiritual purpose of the space which is always a guess and sometimes he got it wrong i mean writes i mean but he put those things together you know this is the pattern in the natural world around it and that's going to ripple through the building this is the way that the people use the structure i'm going to make that pattern fuse with the nature and then what is a greater spiritual ideal that i can infuse with this and you know the buildings are kind of like altars in that way um yeah but uh and and that makes him yeah he threw out all of the you know uh art nouveau or not our new what's the word though arts you know classes classical detail but he also wasn't totally a modernist
要研究他们在做什么，然后我要看看这个空间更大的精神目的，这总是一个猜测，有时他弄错了，我的意思是赖特，我的意思是，但他把这些东西放在了一起，你知道，这是周围自然世界中的模式，那将通过建筑产生涟漪，这是人们使用结构的方式，我要让那个模式与自然融合，然后我能注入什么更大的精神理想，你知道，建筑在某种程度上就像祭坛，嗯，是的，但呃，而且这使他，是的，他抛弃了所有，你知道，呃，新艺术运动，或者不是我们的新，那个词是什么，艺术，你知道，古典细节，但他也不是完全的现代主义者，
because he was adhering to this kind of pretty timeless structure. Well, that generation could do that because while they were creating a modernist sensibility, they were trained in that old Beaux Arts manner. Now, that's been gone for a hundred years nobody knows how to draw a circle anymore or a curve it's just straight lines and um uh yeah that the the past has been so completely dismissed that my understanding of I went to architecture school but I was in the urban
因为他坚持这种相当永恒的结构。嗯，那一代人可以做到这一点，因为当他们创造一种现代主义感性时，他们受过那种旧的布杂艺术（Beaux Arts）训练。现在，那已经消失了一百年了，没有人知道如何再画一个圆圈或一条曲线了，只有直线，而且，嗯，呃，是的，过去已经被如此彻底地否定了，以至于我对，我去过建筑学院，但我是在城市
planning program so no no design training in that sense but what I see coming out of architecture school is not only does your design have to be different but every time your process is going to be different as well because you have to create a new one-time language and process to create this one-time building everything it's almost like um a really severe form of of jazz theory you know every piece of music has to be played differently every time you play it, or you're just compromising. Yeah, it's interesting you said that people are expected to reinvent a new process every time. In architecture school, I haven't been in architecture school, so I don't know trends in that in that field at least
规划项目，所以没有那种意义上的设计训练，但我看到从建筑学院出来的不只是你的设计必须与众不同，而且每次你的过程也会不同，因为你必须创造一种新的、一次性的语言和过程来创造这个一次性的建筑，一切，这几乎就像，一种非常严重的爵士乐理论，你知道，每一首音乐每次演奏时都必须以不同的方式演奏，否则你只是在妥协。是的，你说人们被期望每次都重新发明一个过程，这很有趣。在建筑学院，我没去过建筑学院，所以我不知道那个领域的趋势，至少
you know i know them from the 70s vernacular architecture and stuff but right right after that yeah well it's um it it's a a really difficult thing that i think um to try and overcome because when you're in a mindset that discounts everything except itself um you know i i think it takes a civilizational collapse um i'm not sure that it's something that can be reformed incrementally well it's like craftsmen in architecture you know wr right could come in and say i kind of want this pattern to repeat and trust the tradesmen that were skilled enough to do that but we don't have any skilled labor left in this country we outsourced everything in the 80s you know but get tail end of industry got sent overseas we don't make anything and um we we
你知道，我从70年代的乡土建筑之类的东西中了解它们，但就在那之后，是的，嗯，这是一个非常困难的事情，我认为，嗯，试图克服，因为当你处于一种除了自身之外什么都不考虑的心态时，你知道，我认为这需要一场文明的崩溃，我不确定这是否是可以逐步改革的事情。嗯，这就像建筑中的工匠，你知道，赖特可以进来，说我想要这种模式重复，并信任那些有足够技能的工匠来做到这一点，但我们这个国家没有任何熟练劳动力了，我们在80年代外包了一切，你知道，工业的末端被送到了海外，我们什么都不生产，而且，嗯，我们
don't eat that knowledge is institutional it's like um people were talking about you know the spacex and boeing all these companies are trying to build these big rockets to lift cargo they were like we were building the saturn v you know we had the heavy lifter rock you know i'm not terribly into rocket science but they're like we had all this stuff in the 70s and 80s why this is 1950s designs you know built in the 60s and 70s like right why can't you just go back and do it? You already did it. And people were like, none of the infrastructure is there. None of the people are there. There are people who knew just how to make that ring. There were whole supply chains to get this type of mineral to be, you know, and all of that's gone. You have to restart with the ability to build that you have. And we have less ability to build now in 2023 than we had in 1950.
不，那种知识是制度性的，就像，嗯，人们在谈论，你知道，SpaceX和波音，所有这些公司都在试图建造这些大火箭来运送货物，他们就像，我们当时在建造土星五号，你知道，我们有重型运载火箭，你知道，我不太热衷于火箭科学，但他们就像，我们在70年代和80年代有所有这些东西，为什么这是1950年代的设计，你知道，建于60年代和70年代，就像，对，为什么你不能回去做呢？你已经做到了。人们就像，没有任何基础设施在那里。没有任何人在那里。有知道如何制造那个环的人。有整个供应链来获取这种矿物，你知道，所有这些都消失了。你必须从你拥有的建造能力重新开始。而且我们在2023年拥有的建造能力比1950年少。
My, it just makes me think my think my ex-father-in-law was an aeronautical engineer with Pratt & Whitney. All he did for his 35-year career was design fan blades for jet engines. That's it. That's all he did. How long, what's the angle of the curve, what metal do you use? That's all he did.
我的，这只是让我想，我的前岳父是普惠公司（Pratt & Whitney）的航空工程师。他35年的职业生涯所做的就是为喷气发动机设计风扇叶片。就是这样。这就是他所做的一切。多长时间，曲线的角度是多少，你用什么金属？这就是他所做的一切。
And so with this sort of specialization. It's a lifetime of experience that you can't just read a book or plug in a formula into a computer program and then get that expertise back. It's half art, half science, even in the hard sciences. Yeah. And that's just counted. Yeah. hard sciences yeah and that's just counted yeah well you know i know uh a lot of people the decline in architecture and urban planning and cities you're talking about you know is written about in 1880 but a lot of the things people tie that to or i've heard people make a case for is is um about planned obsolescence and the american family's access to debt. What happens is that you have
所以有了这种专业化。这是一生的经验，你不能只是读一本书或把公式输入计算机程序，然后就能找回那种专业知识。这是半艺术，半科学，即使在硬科学中也是如此。是的。而且这只是被忽略了。是的，硬科学，是的，而且这只是被忽略了，是的，嗯，你知道，我知道，呃，很多人，你谈到的建筑、城市规划和城市的衰落，你知道，在1880年就有记载，但人们将其联系起来的很多事情，或者我听说人们提出的理由，是关于计划报废和美国家庭获得债务的机会。发生的事情是，你拥有
this precious cameo that came from England with your family or whatever, and it stays in the family and these things are special and they kind of define the family. And we would build a chair to be taken apart and sanded down and last a lifetime. You're not building things that are disposable. And then all of a sudden, these companies figure out that you can make more money if you make the person buy the thing every year. But the problem is they don't have enough money to do it. So you sell in the future and you say, okay, well, go ahead and get the washing machine today and then pay it off over two years and it'll break in a year and you'll need another one. And that changes the way that we live. And this way where we stop trying to, we just start trying to survive, you know, and get the thing that we have to have not the thing that we want or that is Beautiful or that enriches our lives, but just okay
这个珍贵的浮雕，它是和你家人一起从英国来的，或者其他什么，它留在家里，这些东西很特别，它们定义了这个家庭。我们会建造一把椅子，可以拆卸、打磨，并持续一生。你建造的不是一次性的东西。然后突然之间，这些公司发现，如果你让人们每年都买这个东西，你可以赚更多的钱。但问题是他们没有足够的钱来做。所以你透支未来，你说，好吧，今天去买洗衣机，然后分两年付清，它一年就会坏掉，你需要另一个。这改变了我们的生活方式。这种方式，我们停止尝试，我们只是开始尝试生存，你知道，得到我们必须拥有的东西，而不是我们想要的，或者美丽的，或者丰富我们生活的东西，只是好吧，
I have to have a car have to have a washing machine have to have a dishwasher have to have a garbage disposal have to Have this and then they're breaking and that process of maintenance and all that becomes something that yeah, and the time and psychic energy involved You know. I'm quite well educated. I've got a master's degree and a number of postgraduate training. I'm not the smartest one on the bus, but by no means a dummy and it's overwhelming. You know we have to choose our trash hauler and where we get our electricity from and who we're going to get our
我必须有一辆车，必须有一台洗衣机，必须有一台洗碗机，必须有一个垃圾处理器，必须有这个，然后它们坏了，维护的过程和所有这些都变成了，是的，以及涉及的时间和心理能量。你知道。我受过很好的教育。我有硕士学位和一些研究生培训。我不是车上最聪明的人，但绝不是傻瓜，而且这让人不知所措。你知道，我们必须选择我们的垃圾清运工，我们从哪里获得电力，我们从谁那里获得
telephone service from and on and on and all these choices and you have to do research and it's it's just overwhelmed just like like you said surviving rather than flourishing uh is is a full-time effort and i can understand why there's a generational shift um in so i spent a lot of time with 30-somethings, 20-somethings on a regular basis. And there's this attitude that, yeah, whatever. I'll buy the $20 IKEA chair instead of the $100 better one. Because it's not going to be around. I'm going to move anyway.
电话服务，等等，所有这些选择，你必须做研究，这简直让人不知所措，就像你说的，生存而不是繁荣，是一项全职工作，我可以理解为什么会有代际转变，嗯，所以我经常和30多岁、20多岁的人在一起。有一种态度是，是的，随便吧。我会买20美元的宜家椅子，而不是100美元更好的椅子。因为它不会长久。反正我要搬家。
Everything is disposable now that was like ikea's ad in sweden was like a lamp on the curb and it had this sad music and then it was like don't feel bad for the lamp that's in the trash and the guy's carrying a new lamp and that's it that was the original yeah it was like, no real bad to throw all this stuff away. Yeah. You can get a new one. We do it to ourselves now. Yeah. You know, we bought into it and it's just, it's just easier to go along.
现在一切都是一次性的，就像宜家在瑞典的广告，路边有一盏灯，放着悲伤的音乐，然后就像，不要为垃圾桶里的灯感到难过，那个人正带着一盏新灯，就是这样，那是最初的，是的，就像，扔掉所有这些东西没什么大不了的。是的。你可以买一个新的。我们现在对自己这样做。是的。你知道，我们接受了它，而且，这只是，顺其自然更容易。
Well, in a lot of modernism, you know, like AI or something, it's like, people are like, Hey, this is kind of a bad idea,
嗯，在很多现代主义中，你知道，比如人工智能或其他什么，就像，人们就像，嘿，这有点是个坏主意，
but we can't quit doing it because this is the way it's going. And if I quit doing it, I'm behind, you know, right. There's not, no one knows how to stop it, but they do agree that it's not a good idea to do the thing that we're doing today and we'll continue to do more tomorrow. I'm not sure what problem AI is intended to solve. What are we going to be able to do in the future that we've never been able to do before?
但我们不能停止这样做，因为这就是它的发展方向。如果我停止这样做，我就落后了，你知道，对。没有，没有人知道如何停止它，但他们确实同意，做我们今天正在做的事情并不是一个好主意，而且明天我们会继续做更多。我不确定人工智能旨在解决什么问题。未来我们将能够做些什么我们以前从未能做到的事情？
Well, nothing I've been told. The microcosm of American access to debt affecting all this stuff also spills out 20 years later into economy. And so it's like nobody wants to just say, all right, I'm going to go to the factory and make the thing and then go home and have this life. And we can have a middle class. Everybody is like, we'll throw 80% of the country into poverty to try and gamble that maybe you'll be one of the ones that gets to be a billionaire. You know, and there's this strange thing where it's like, you can have a company that makes a really good product that works really well. And nobody wants to fund it and it doesn't work. But you can be a country that's a company that says well i'm going to be a monopoly and
嗯，没人告诉我。美国家庭获得债务影响所有这些东西的微观层面，20年后也蔓延到了经济中。所以就像没有人想只是说，好吧，我要去工厂制造那个东西，然后回家过这种生活。我们可以有一个中产阶级。每个人都像，我们会把国家80%的人扔进贫困中，去赌博，也许你会成为那些能成为亿万富翁的人之一。你知道，有一种奇怪的事情，就像，你可以拥有一家制造出真正好用、效果很好的产品的公司。没有人想资助它，它行不通。但你可以成为一个国家，一个公司，说好吧，我要成为垄断者，而且
every we're just chasing this monopoly you know like amazon was a company that sold books and then they turned into this company that wanted to sell you every single thing that existed and they're not even like a great bookstore anymore like that's forgotten you know just being a bookstore is not enough you know twitter was this thing that worked pretty well like people were sharing information and everything and it wasn't rewarded you know it didn't make money it had to be oh we have to have some crazy pipe dream vision but they never really pay off i mean netflix you know borrowed all this money and made all this stuff now they're going bankrupt and trying to figure out how to make money. People don't realize none of these companies
我们只是在追逐这种垄断，你知道，就像亚马逊是一家卖书的公司，然后他们变成了这家想卖给你存在的所有东西的公司，他们甚至不再像一家伟大的书店了，就像那被遗忘了，你知道，仅仅成为一家书店是不够的，你知道，推特是那种运作得相当好的东西，就像人们在分享信息和一切，它没有得到回报，你知道，它没有赚钱，它必须是，哦，我们必须有一些疯狂的白日梦愿景，但它们从未真正得到回报，我的意思是Netflix，你知道，借了所有这些钱，制作了所有这些东西，现在他们要破产了，试图弄清楚如何赚钱。人们没有意识到这些公司中没有一家
make money. They're still burning through venture capital. That's where we are. Spotify loses money. Pandora loses money. Uber loses. They lose billions of dollars because everyone's hoping, well, maybe when Uber is a complete monopoly, then the self-driving car will mean we don't have to pay the driver and then that will be a model to profitability. But that's a pipe dream of a guest, depending on AI being able to do certain things. I don't even know what the pitch for Spotify being profitable is. I mean, they lose a million dollars a day. But all of these things are based on this fantasy of the future that's going to be huge.
赚钱。他们仍在烧掉风险投资。这就是我们所处的境地。Spotify亏钱。Pandora亏钱。Uber亏钱。他们亏损数十亿美元，因为每个人都在希望，好吧，也许当Uber成为完全的垄断者时，自动驾驶汽车将意味着我们不必支付司机费用，那么那将是一个盈利模式。但这只是一个基于人工智能能够做某些事情的白日梦。我甚至不知道Spotify盈利的卖点是什么。我的意思是，他们每天亏损一百万美元。但所有这些东西都基于这个未来将变得巨大的幻想。
And there's not just, I want to do a job. I'm going to go in and do this thing well that isn't rewarded anymore well this is a a result of the mindset that started back in the 1600s so that that scientific revolution um you know when when you're not connected to something larger in a cosmological sense this is the result um or the alternative would be what what uh uh the french revolution the communist revolution uh provided uh which is the death of tens of millions of people. So there has to be, as little as we understand or respect the spiritual value of religion,
而且不仅仅是，我想做一份工作。我要进去把这件事做好，那不再得到回报了，嗯，这是1600年代开始的心态的结果，所以那个科学革命，嗯，你知道，当你没有在宇宙学意义上与更大的东西连接时，这就是结果，或者替代方案将是，什么，呃，法国大革命，共产主义革命所提供的，也就是数千万人的死亡。所以必须有，尽管我们对宗教的精神价值理解或尊重很少，
if it's not there, the results are not to be surprising. This is just what happens. Well, I mean, maybe another way of saying that is that if there's no higher spiritual principle, if there's no higher aspiration or ability to transcend our base instincts, then all life is is just this competition that is pretty soulless and pretty
如果它不存在，结果也就不足为奇了。这就是发生的事情。嗯，我的意思是，也许另一种说法是，如果没有更高的精神原则，如果没有更高的愿望或超越我们基本本能的能力，那么所有的生活只是这种相当无灵魂和相当
depersonalizing. That's what Nietzsche said, and most people misunderstand his quote, God is dead. People today think that was a call to liberation, and he saw that very much as a disaster. Society losing its center. Society losing its center. Society loses its center.
去人格化的竞争。这就是尼采所说的，大多数人误解了他的名言，“上帝已死”。今天的人们认为那是一种解放的呼吁，而他非常清楚那是一场灾难。社会失去了中心。社会失去了中心。社会失去了中心。
It's going to fall apart and explode. And yeah, World War I, World War II, the entire 20th century, following his prediction, saw how many tens, hundreds of millions of people slaughtered. And we're in a point of relative peace right now. And they couldn't tell you why. You know, we're looking at the world and it's like, what did we do? Why did we do that?
它终将分崩离析并走向毁灭。是的，第一次世界大战、第二次世界大战，整个20世纪，正如他的预言，见证了数以千万计、亿计的人被屠杀。而我们现在正处于一个相对和平的时期。他们却说不出原因。你知道，我们审视这个世界，就像在问：我们做了什么？为什么我们要那样做？
Yeah. Yeah. Well, for the same reasons that you personally, you, me, everyone else, all of us as individuals commit small little mistakes, errors, so on and so forth. Anything that you see going wrong in society is going wrong in you as well. And so one of the things I'm sorry, I didn't mean to cut you off. There's a little bit of a lag. Sometimes I'll start talking and then I hear like the middle of a word and the, I think it was counseling is shaving off the beginning and the ends of the.
是啊。嗯，原因和你我、每个人一样，我们作为个体都会犯下一些小错误，诸如此类。你在社会中看到的任何问题，其实也存在于你自身。所以其中一件事——抱歉，我不是故意打断你。这里有一点延迟。有时我开始说话，然后听到自己话语中间的部分，我想是咨询（系统）削减了开头和结尾。
You're right. Talking sometimes. That's all right. Go ahead. But I was curious, I mean, one of the things that, yeah, the Venus of Willendorf is a pretty big one where you, and for those who aren't familiar, like one of the earliest, they, they call them like the earliest religious artifacts or something.
你说得对。说话有时是这样。没关系。你继续。但我很好奇，我是说，其中一件事，是的，维伦多夫的维纳斯是一个非常重要的例子，对于那些不熟悉的人来说，他们称之为最早的宗教文物之类的东西。
And the reason is, you know, when mankind's evolving and the things that you find, you can find some tools and things, but they're practical. They're a knife or a stabber or a, you know, scraper or something.
原因在于，你知道，当人类在进化时，你发现的东西，你可以找到一些工具之类的，但它们是实用的。它们是刀、刺器、刮刀之类的东西。
And then all of a sudden you see these things that are just for beauty. And that it's telling you that people are kind of trying to figure out a deeper spiritual or artistic function, that they're not just worried about that people are kind of trying to figure out a deeper spiritual or artistic function that they're not just worried about surviving they're also trying to figure out you know what makes them alive or how to be alive or there's some question about identity and so the first figures and largely caves around france are these um like very round very rotund women figures that they're guessing were about fertility and you know the the fattest woman makes is the most healthy and versed the most babies and it was some kind of uh you know uh maybe the supernatural blessing of fertility or just a honoring of fertility or something but the
然后突然间，你看到了这些纯粹为了美而存在的东西。这告诉你，人们正在试图探索一种更深层的精神或艺术功能，他们不仅仅是在担心生存，他们也在试图弄清楚是什么让他们活着，或者如何活着，或者关于身份认同的一些问题。所以最早的雕像，大多在法国的洞穴里，是这些非常圆润、非常丰满的女性形象，他们猜测这与生育有关，你知道，最胖的女人最健康，生的孩子最多，这可能是一种超自然的生育祝福，或者仅仅是对生育的崇拜之类的，但是……
venus of villendorf is one of the most famous i don't think it's the oldest but it's maybe one of the first found um and that's a big place where humanity is looking at itself and they're not. The brain has developed precuneus. And so it's able to perceive itself as this thing outside of the world around it. And no longer is it just processing information. It's actually perceiving it. And part of that perception is self-perception. And then we wonder what we are.
维伦多夫的维纳斯是最著名的雕像之一，我不认为它是最古老的，但它可能是最早被发现的之一。这是一个人类审视自身的重要节点，他们不再仅仅是处理信息。大脑已经进化出了楔前叶，因此它能够将自己感知为世界之外的一个客体。它不再仅仅是处理信息，而是在进行感知。这种感知的一部分就是自我感知。然后我们开始思考我们是什么。
It creates this anxiety and all these problems. What's the joke is, you know, God took a perfectly good monkey and gave it anxiety um and but another kind of big formative thing i think is the first cities like we always assumed because it's the way modern society works that when people came together to build these cities and it happened a couple different places it wasn't just like one spot that they did. We did it because it was more safe or that we would be able to have more food or the quality of life was better. And that, you know,
这产生了焦虑和所有这些问题。有个笑话是，上帝拿走了一只原本好好的猴子，给了它焦虑。但我觉得另一个重大的形成性事件是第一批城市的出现。因为现代社会运作的方式，我们总是假设当人们聚集在一起建造这些城市时——这发生在几个不同的地方，不仅仅是一个地方——我们这样做是因为更安全，或者我们能有更多的食物，或者生活质量更好。而且，你知道，
more people kind of doing work. Well, that's a pretty industrial revolution idea. Really. When you go and you look at these cities that people are coming together to build, the quality of life went down. People had less access to food.
更多的人在工作。嗯，那是一个相当工业革命式的想法。真的。当你去观察人们聚集在一起建造的这些城市时，生活质量其实下降了。人们获取食物的途径变少了。
They had to work more. They lived less long, yet they still did it. We're called to build some kind of project there. And I always thought that was an interesting idea. Yeah, that's the usual, I don't know about the usual, but quite often you'll hear that cities are simply that artifact of the patriarchy in which leaders could control the masses. So cities and religion have that negative
他们不得不工作更多。寿命更短，但他们还是这么做了。我们被召唤去完成某种工程。我一直觉得这是一个有趣的观点。是的，这是通常的说法，我不知道是不是通常，但你经常会听到城市仅仅是父权制的产物，统治者可以在其中控制大众。所以城市和宗教都有那种负面
connotation because they're all about control. And I think what you said about being called to do something. Yeah, we're we evolutionarily we grew out of our our monkey background. We still have the monkey brain that the Buddhists talk about. The brain is way back here and it's still jumping around. But that process of psychological awakening seems to provoke us to do, to create in ways that no other species does. Lots of other species will. Prairie dogs make prairie dog towns and bees make hives and lots of animals make homes for themselves birds in their nests but humans go in a different direction that isn't necessarily practical we do things for metaphorical reasons there's some concept or idea that doesn't help us survive,
含义，因为它们都是关于控制的。我觉得你说的关于被召唤去做某事很有道理。是的，我们在进化上脱离了猴子的背景。我们仍然拥有佛教徒所说的“猴子大脑”。大脑就在这里，它仍然跳来跳去。但那种心理觉醒的过程似乎促使我们以其他物种所没有的方式去创造。许多其他物种也会这样做。草原犬鼠建造城镇，蜜蜂建造蜂巢，许多动物为自己建造家园，鸟类筑巢，但人类走向了一个不一定实用的方向。我们出于隐喻的原因做事，有一些概念或想法并不能帮助我们生存，
but we think makes life better somehow. And that's one of the strongest drives we have. And you, you, you just can't deny it. It's like the, the writing of this book for me, I was impelled to do that
但我们认为这在某种程度上让生活变得更好。这是我们拥有的最强大的驱动力之一。你，你，你就是无法否认它。就像写这本书对我来说，我是被迫去做的。
it wasn't something I was planning on doing or had always hoped to do I was in a sense I was sort of forced to do it so there's something that's trying to burst out from the unconscious and make itself real and for me the greatest that's trying to burst out from the unconscious and make itself real. And for me, the greatest, certainly the largest thing that we build physically is a city. It's the largest manifestation of human desire. And we've really done it very, badly for three four hundred years at least a hundred years here in the United States
这不是我计划要做或一直希望做的事情，在某种意义上，我算是被迫去做的。所以有些东西正试图从潜意识中迸发出来，并使自己成为现实。对我来说，我们从物理上建造的最伟大的，当然也是最大的东西就是城市。它是人类欲望最大的体现。而且我们在过去三四百年，至少在过去一百年里，在美国，做得非常糟糕。
how do you reorient that so I think LaFont was pointing the way LaFont did not have any particular personal spiritual attitude. I don't think he was a particularly thoughtful person. We would probably call him, oh, he'd be somewhere on the autistic spectrum today. Yeah. Maybe something of a narcissist. Oh, he'd be somewhere on the autistic spectrum today. Yeah. Maybe something of a narcissist. Well, I think a lot of obsessive creatives, maybe they're not all on the spectrum.
你如何重新定位它？所以我认为朗方（L'Enfant）指明了方向。朗方没有任何特别的个人精神态度。我不认为他是一个特别深思熟虑的人。我们今天可能会说他，哦，他会在自闭症谱系的某个位置。是的。也许有点自恋。嗯，我想很多痴迷的创作者，也许他们并不都在谱系上。
Some of them are, but they have that similar type, you know, Steve Jobs, the whatever. They see this vision and they're forcing it to be worn. And the people who have that impulse a little less lightly maybe don't get that project done you know they don't ram it through yeah well he was he was not well liked um why was he selected what was it that made them select him washington deeply respected him knew that he was kind of, again, today we would at a minimum call him a jerk. But so L'Enfant's story, he was the son of a court architect, a court artist under Louis XIV. His father painted all the grand artwork for the king. And so L'Enfant was raised in Versailles and the courts of the king and so on and so forth. So he had that classic Baroque understanding of art and design. And he was well placed to end up in a very socially upward movement
有些人是，但他们有相似的类型，你知道，史蒂夫·乔布斯之类的。他们看到了这个愿景，并强迫它实现。而那些冲动稍微弱一点的人可能就没能完成那个项目，你知道，他们没有强行推进。是的，嗯，他不太受欢迎。嗯，为什么选中他？是什么让他们选中了他？华盛顿非常尊重他，知道他有点……再说一次，今天我们至少会称他为混蛋。但关于朗方的故事，他是路易十四手下的一位宫廷建筑师、宫廷艺术家的儿子。他的父亲为国王绘制了所有宏伟的艺术品。所以朗方是在凡尔赛宫和国王的宫廷中长大的，诸如此类。所以他拥有那种经典的巴洛克艺术和设计理解。他在职业和社会地位上都处于非常有利的上升位置。
professionally and socially. But when he was 20 years old or something he came to america to fight in the revolution i think he was very much um passionate about glory and all that sort of thing you know it wasn't going to be a war in france during his lifetime he needed to find one he went and found one um and he was he And he served under Washington, Valley Forge. He met Hamilton and all the and was wounded during the war and ended up as an architect in New York and his major project there was two first was converting city hall in New York to the continental congressional hall where congress meet. And he did a fine job there. He was hired to design some of the early coins and medallions and so forth for the nation. And he designed the first inauguration for George Washington, put together the whole
但在他20岁左右的时候，他来到美国参加革命。我想他非常热衷于荣耀之类的东西，你知道，在他有生之年法国不会有战争，他需要找到一场战争，他去了并找到了一场。他曾在华盛顿手下服役，在福吉谷。他遇到了汉密尔顿和所有人，并在战争中受伤，最终成为纽约的一名建筑师。他在那里的主要项目有两个，第一个是将纽约市政厅改建为大陆会议厅，供国会开会。他在那里做得很好。他被聘请为国家设计一些早期的硬币和奖章之类的东西。他还设计了乔治·华盛顿的第一次就职典礼，组织了整个
big event. And then it came time to select the location for the new Capitol. And that's really, really what LaFont had hoped to do. And he wrote to Washington specifically asking for that job and Washington gave it to him. So they had that personal connection, and Washington knew of his skill. I don't really know much about Washington's design taste. I mean, it was what I guess you'd call that colonial architecture at that point, and he had an ovular room in a house that he liked, and so the white
大型活动。然后到了选择新首都地点的时候了。这确实是朗方一直希望做的事情。他专门写信给华盛顿请求那份工作，华盛顿给了他。所以他们有那种私人联系，华盛顿也知道他的技术。我不太了解华盛顿的设计品味。我是说，那是我猜你会称之为当时的殖民建筑，他在房子里有一个他喜欢的椭圆形房间，所以白宫
house architect kind of all i know about his architectural taste is that he liked oval rooms or at least the architect thought that um that may be thomas jefferson um there's an oval room in monticello i thought um the white house design was um yeah that, that was James Hoban, I believe, who designed the White House. LaFont had designed buildings for both the White House and the President. I don't mean LaFont designing the White House. I just was saying I knew that when Washington was choosing the White House plan, that that was what the architect... I don't remember the name of the architect of the White House,
建筑师……我所知道的关于他建筑品味的全部就是他喜欢椭圆形房间，或者至少建筑师是这么认为的……那可能是托马斯·杰斐逊……我记得蒙蒂塞洛有一个椭圆形房间……白宫的设计是……是的，那是詹姆斯·霍班（James Hoban），我相信是他设计了白宫。朗方为白宫和总统都设计过建筑。我不是说朗方设计了白宫。我只是说我知道当华盛顿选择白宫方案时，那是建筑师……我不记得白宫建筑师的名字了，
but that he had done a bunch of oval rooms because he thought that washington liked one from his house that's all i know about his architectural taste what about washington other than the friend connection would make him choose lafonce designs well he really did um so what's interesting washington and and jeff had two very, very different mindsets. Jefferson despised cities. And Jefferson had come up with a design for the city that was like 10 square blocks along. He wanted like rural agrarian kingdoms, like all these farmsteads surrounded by farm you know farmland basically like the house as the city but then the thing that was so silly about that is it's like who are you selling the product
但他做了很多椭圆形房间，因为他认为华盛顿喜欢他房子里的那个。这就是我所知道的关于他建筑品味的全部。除了朋友关系，华盛顿还有什么理由选择朗方的设计？嗯，他确实……所以有趣的是，华盛顿和杰斐逊有两种非常、非常不同的心态。杰斐逊鄙视城市。杰斐逊曾提出过一个城市设计，大约是10个街区长。他想要像农村农业王国那样，所有这些农场被农田包围，你知道，基本上就是把房子当作城市。但那件事愚蠢的地方在于，如果每个人都住在农场里，你把产品卖给谁？
to if everyone is living on a farm there is nobody who is buying your stuff so you can drink all this french wine that's right you know but jefferson wasn't really well he he wasn't that great at you know finances or economics as we you know had some good ideas about metaphor and government, but he dies penniless. Library of Congress exists just because they threw him up by buying his library so he couldn't afford to eat. I mean, he just really sat back on his farm talking about how cities were bad. Everyone should live on a farm. Ordering luxurious products from France and Italy into going into debt from cities in Europe, writing about how he hated cities.
如果每个人都住在农场里，就没有人买你的东西，所以你不能喝这些法国葡萄酒。没错，你知道，但杰斐逊在财务或经济方面并不是很擅长，正如我们所知，他在隐喻和政府方面有一些好的想法，但他死时身无分文。国会图书馆的存在仅仅是因为他们通过购买他的藏书来救济他，否则他连饭都吃不起。我是说，他真的只是坐在他的农场里谈论城市有多糟糕。每个人都应该住在农场里。却从欧洲的城市订购奢侈品，并因此负债累累，同时还在写文章说他讨厌城市。
I mean, so silly. There's no farm without a city and there's no city without a farm. So that was a real tension early on. But Washington was very much more of an empire builder. Although, interestingly, it was Jefferson who completed the Louisiana Purchase. In fact, the reason that our Midwest today is so spread out and gridded. Jefferson basically laid out the entire area of the Louisiana Purchase, what we now know as Midwest. How many states? 10, 15 states, whatever it is, in 160 acre plots in a grid.
我是说，太愚蠢了。没有城市就没有农场，没有农场就没有城市。所以早期存在着真正的张力。但华盛顿更像是一个帝国建设者。尽管有趣的是，是杰斐逊完成了路易斯安那购地案。事实上，我们今天的中西部地区之所以如此分散和网格化，是因为杰斐逊基本上把路易斯安那购地案的整个区域，也就是我们现在所知的中西部，划分成了160英亩的网格地块。有多少个州？10个，15个州，不管是多少。
And yeah, he thought that we should all be yeoman farmers and that would be heaven on earth. But Washington was very different. He understood that the United States had the potential to become a global superpower, not just economically or politically, but philosophically. He felt like the old order was dying and he was ushering in a new one with birthing this nation that was ultimately going to be the model of all nations.
是的，他认为我们都应该成为自耕农，那将是人间天堂。但华盛顿非常不同。他明白美国有潜力成为全球超级大国，不仅是在经济或政治上，而且是在哲学上。他觉得旧秩序正在消亡，他正在迎来一个新的秩序，孕育这个最终将成为所有国家典范的国家。
And the whole point was democracy, spreading democracy. That's always been what the U.S. has been about. And in order to in people's minds infuse a lot of hope and desire and understanding of this, he and LaFont both agreed that the capital city should be absolutely magnificent and reflect that level of value in its design. It's designed almost like a garden. Like you look at the layout, it looks like the gardens at Versailles or something, the way it kind of unfolds and is bifurcated with streets.
而重点就是民主，传播民主。这一直以来都是美国的核心。为了在人们心中注入希望、渴望和理解，他和朗方都同意首都应该绝对宏伟，并在设计中反映出那种价值水平。它被设计得几乎像一个花园。就像你看看布局，它看起来像凡尔赛宫的花园之类的，它展开的方式以及被街道分叉的方式。
I mean, it's not designed the way that European cities were. Well, in fact, Laffont grew up with spending time in Versailles. And a lot of people will, a lot, some authors have pointed to that as the source of Laffont's inspiration, but Laffont did something different. In Versailles, the angled pathways and streets all converge in one particular place, the king's bedroom. That's where all, visually, all the paths lead to the king's bedroom. That's where all the power lay. What LaFont was doing was something much more dispersed. The power was in three places. He placed the Capitol building at the center of the people, not the White House.
我是说，它的设计方式与欧洲城市不同。事实上，朗方在凡尔赛宫度过了成长时光。很多人，一些作者指出那是朗方灵感的来源，但朗方做了不同的事情。在凡尔赛宫，倾斜的路径和街道都汇聚在一个特定的地方，国王的卧室。那就是视觉上所有路径通向的地方，国王的卧室。那是所有权力所在的地方。朗方所做的是更分散的事情。权力在三个地方。他把国会大厦放在了人民的中心，而不是白宫。
The Capitol is the centerpiece. The White House also, the streets, both for the Capitol and the White House, the streets don't terminate on the center of the building. They terminate in the doorways. So when you look at a map, you'll see, for instance, Pennsylvania Avenue going through in front of the White House. But it's actually kind of offset because the streets don't intersect in the middle of the building they arrive at the doorways people are welcome here that's the idea um so lafont had um and washington both shared this this vision a very, very different political order. So Novus Ordo Seclorum was, you know, that new world order was very much what they were all about.
国会大厦是中心点。白宫也是，街道，无论是国会大厦还是白宫，街道都没有终止在建筑的中心。它们终止在门口。所以当你查看地图时，你会看到，例如，宾夕法尼亚大道穿过白宫前。但它实际上有点偏移，因为街道不在建筑中间交叉，它们到达门口。人们在这里受到欢迎，这就是那个想法。嗯，所以朗方和华盛顿都分享了这个愿景，一个非常、非常不同的政治秩序。所以“新秩序”（Novus Ordo Seclorum），你知道，那个新世界秩序正是他们所追求的。
Well, and I think that was something that Washington saw too, because of what we were talking about in the beginning, that idea of land that he saw, this country had land that went on and on like it sort of threw a wrench in every america's infinite seemingly infinite resources sort of threw a wrench in everyone's um every european philosopher's plans you know even marx was like i don't you know like what do i do labor theory doesn't really work if land is free, but eventually they'll run out of it. I will, you'll see, you know, and Jung, Jung was afraid of America. He saw the, um, capacity for, um, the kind of charismatic religious movements and, um, just power. Um, but I think Washington, when he, it wasn't that he was in this disagreement where he was like, well, I want to leave Britain and they're taxing us or something in the way that Franklin and some of the other ones were.
嗯，我认为这也是华盛顿所看到的，因为我们一开始谈论的关于土地的想法，他看到这个国家拥有无尽的土地，这似乎给每个人的……美国看似无限的资源给每个欧洲哲学家的计划都造成了阻碍，你知道，连马克思都说，我不……你知道，如果土地是免费的，劳动价值论就不太管用，但最终他们会用完的。我会，你会看到的，你知道，荣格，荣格害怕美国。他看到了那种……对魅力型宗教运动的容纳能力，以及……纯粹的力量。嗯，但我认为华盛顿，当他……这不是说他处于这种分歧中，他并不是说，好吧，我想离开英国，他们正在向我们征税之类的，像富兰克林和其他人那样。
And I think he really saw this old order that says that your power is handed down by God because you have a plot of land in England does not work anymore. There's all this land, man. Like, you're not going to get to tell me or these people what to do. And he, it wasn't as personal for him i think he felt like it was an inevitability if he didn't do it it would be done by someone else well it was just there was a breaking away that was going to happen and that all of the european order was based on that so america had to represent this new thing um that was the the next thing that they couldn't see there yet. And I think that took some time for the founding fathers, certainly a certain group of them,
我认为他真的看到了这种旧秩序，即你的权力是由上帝赋予的，因为你在英国有一块土地，这不再行得通了。这里有这么多土地，伙计。就像，你不能再告诉我和这些人该做什么。而且他……我认为对他来说这并不那么个人化，他觉得这是一种必然，如果他不这样做，别人也会做。嗯，这只是发生了一种分裂，而所有的欧洲秩序都是基于此的。所以美国必须代表这种新事物，那是他们当时还看不到的下一个阶段。我认为这花了一些时间让开国元勋们，当然是其中的一部分，
because they were the American equivalent of the aristocracy. They were all the big wealthy landowners. And what they were doing was creating a system in which their legacy personally wasn't going to continue. Most of the founding fathers at the beginning of the war, I don't think, wanted to leave. They didn't want to break away. They simply wanted more autonomy. But they loved their connection to England and so forth. But over the course of time, the relationship with England got so bad.
因为他们是美国版的贵族。他们都是拥有大量土地的富人。他们所做的是创造一个他们个人的遗产不会延续下去的系统。大多数开国元勋在战争开始时，我不认为他们想离开。他们不想分裂。他们只是想要更多的自治权。但他们热爱与英国的联系等等。但随着时间的推移，与英国的关系变得非常糟糕。
It's just goofy little things like the Boston Tea Party. What caused that? Interesting story there um from what i understand the mogul empire in india had collapsed and england uh through the east india company basically took over and for a variety of economic reasons all of a a sudden the tea trade was in an uproar. And they had all this tea and there was no place to ship it. So they decided to bring a whole lot of tea to the Americas. And what they ended up doing was actually lowering the price of tea but adding a tax to it
这只是像波士顿倾茶事件这样愚蠢的小事。是什么导致的？那里有个有趣的故事。据我所知，印度的莫卧儿帝国崩溃了，英国通过东印度公司基本上接管了那里，由于各种经济原因，茶叶贸易突然陷入混乱。他们有所有的茶叶，却没地方运。所以他们决定把大量的茶叶运到美洲。他们最终做的是实际上降低了茶叶的价格，但增加了一项税收。
so let's say before all of this happened t cost a dollar a pound whatever it was um after when after the east india company uh took on uh control when the Mobile Empire collapsed. Tea was down to 90 cents a pound, but the British added a 5 cent tax to it. So tea was actually cheaper, but there was now a tax. What a stupid thing to rebel against. We're giving you something cheaper. Everyone wins. But it was just this,
所以假设在这一切发生之前，茶价是一美元一磅，不管是多少。在东印度公司在莫卧儿帝国崩溃后接管控制权之后。茶价降到了90美分一磅，但英国人加了5美分的税。所以茶实际上更便宜了，但现在有了税。反抗这个真是太愚蠢了。我们给你更便宜的东西。每个人都赢了。但这只是……
it was one of those Jungian moments where the archetype breaks in and it's time for a large change. This is how we're going to make it happen. Well, I think that is one of those kind of very American archetypes is freedom for the lack of a better word, but it's a rebellious freedom. Like, we have the right to do this, even though it's the wrong thing to do.
这是荣格式的时刻之一，原型介入，是时候进行大规模变革了。这就是我们将要实现它的方式。嗯，我认为这是一种非常典型的美国原型，用一个更好的词来说就是自由，但它是一种叛逆的自由。就像，我们有权这样做，即使这是错误的事情。
It's a fight that we have over and over again. It's like, yeah, I guess. I'm going to hurt myself on principle just to show you. Yeah, you do get that. There is that kind of trickster archetype. Yeah. And that's what Gibbons was afraid of with America. There's just so much power and capability in a very, very psychologically immature as a culture.
这是一场我们反复进行的斗争。就像，是的，我想是吧。我原则上要伤害自己，只是为了向你证明。是的，你确实会得到那个。有一种骗子原型。是的。而那正是吉本斯（Gibbons）对美国所担心的。作为一个文化，在心理上非常、非常不成熟，却拥有如此多的权力和能力。
Yeah, I think he saw it as a teenage country. It was starting to act up and rebel against dad. It's mineral deposits were just coming in and going through an awkward growth spurt. Yeah, but I think it was necessary. You know, when you think about Jung and his reconciliation of opposites, well, there has to be an opposite to reconcile. In a sense, we had to go through, at least up to this point, 500 years of the scientific revolution and this technological, bureaucratic way of thinking in order to have something to integrate and bring that together. Well, and other countries had an anchored identity much hundreds of years before the
是的，我想他把它看作一个十几岁的国家。它开始表现得叛逆，反抗父亲。它的矿产资源刚刚涌入，并经历了一个尴尬的生长突增期。是的，但我认为这是必要的。你知道，当你想到荣格和他对对立面的调和时，嗯，必须有一个对立面来调和。在某种意义上，我们必须经历，至少到目前为止，500年的科学革命和这种技术、官僚的思维方式，才能有一些东西来整合并把它们结合在一起。嗯，其他国家在科学革命前几百年就有了一个锚定的身份。所以他们有更多的锚，尽管那改变了很多事情。美国是第一个完全建立在它之上的国家之一。对。所以它会是……我们现在会说我们在哪里？你知道，那个兄弟会男孩从大学毕业了，现在必须找一份成年人的工作，可以这么说。嗯，我认为这也是美国历史中被遗漏的事情之一，那就是工业革命的中心是美国的主要增长点。所以这么多工业来到这里的一些原因是，你不能在欧洲重新发明同样的东西，但你可以在美国窃取专利，因为他们不会引渡你。
scientific revolution. So they sort of had more of an anchor, even though that changed a lot of things. America was one of the first countries built solely on it. Right. So it's going to be, where would we say we are now? You know, the frat boy is graduated from college and has to get a grown-up job now, so to speak. Well, and I think that's one of the things that gets lost in American history, too, is it's like in the middle of the Industrial Revolution is the main growth of America. And so some of the reasons so much industry came here was that you couldn't reinvent the same thing in Europe, but you could steal patents in America because they were going to extradite you.
所以你可以记住这个专利引擎或这个冲压工厂的工作方式，然后把它画在餐巾纸上，航行到美国，用这种全新的技术成为百万富翁。是的，那完全正确。嗯，这就是茶如何到达印度的。印度没有茶。它纯粹是中国的，他们控制得非常严。英国人派了一个间谍去
So you could just memorize the way that this patengin worked or this stamping factory and then draw it on a napkin and sail to America and become a millionaire with this brand new technology. Yeah, that's exact. Well, that's how tea got to India. There was no tea in India. It was purely Chinese and they controlled it very tightly. The English sent a spy to
中国的某个地方，偷了一堆种子，把它们带到了印度的大吉岭，并开始了印度的（茶叶种植），因为中国人开始征收太多的税之类的。所以，是的，这就是世界运作的方式。是的。嗯，这很有趣。
somewhere in China, stole a bunch of seeds and took them to Darjeeling in India and started the Indian, because the Chinese were starting to tax too much or something like that. So, yeah, this is how the world works. Yeah. Well, it's interesting stuff.
我是说，我想也许总结一下，如果有人，你知道，说，好吧，你在谈论所有这些高谈阔论的想法，说你应该在你的砖瓦和街道下拥有灵性，但这看起来是什么样的？具体来说，你主张我们做什么不同的事情？你知道，像克里尔（Krier）这样的人希望我们回到早期的欧洲城市，希望把所有的建筑变回希腊神庙，并拥有一个以行人为主的社会，而不是以汽车为主的社会。他甚至说没有人应该能够使用任何由石油制成的建筑材料。它们应该是天然的。而且，你知道，杜安尼（Duany）非常推崇步行城市，城市应该被使用……我们应该思考它们的功能。我是说，你的……你知道，规则，用一个更好的词来说，你的关于我们需要做什么的论文是什么？很有趣你提到了克里尔关于回到某种古老方式的观点，我的理解是希尔曼（Hillman）真正的愿望是我们都回去崇拜阿佛洛狄忒。
I mean, I guess maybe to wrap up, like if somebody, you know, says, okay, you're talking about all these highfalutin ideas that you should have spirituality in your bricks and mortar and under your streets, but what does that look like? Specifically, what are you advocating for us to do differently? You know, somebody like Krier wants us to go back to the American, the early European city, wants to turn all the buildings back into Greek temples and to have a pedestrian-oriented society instead of a car-oriented society. And he goes as far as to say that no one should be able to use any building materials made
那是他无法回答的一个问题。有一个著名的……我是说，你从没见过希尔曼无话可说。我是说，他从不闭嘴。有个来自加拿大的人，我想是教授，说，你知道，你一直说我们需要回到多神教。我们需要回到希腊。我想如果你让希尔曼去，他会回到母系崇拜。我是说，他想完全退回到潜意识中，我是说他会一直走下去，但那个人
out of petroleum. They should be natural. And, you know, Duany is very much in the walkable city, and the city should be used the way that we should think used the way that um they should we should think about their function i mean what what are your you know rules for the lack of a better word what is what is your thesis about what we need to do it's interesting you mentioned um career's perspective on you know going back to some ancient way my understanding is that hillman's real desire was for us to all go back and worship Aphrodite.
说你一直谈论多神教和希腊人以及所有这些东西，我们为什么要那样做？他们为了皈依基督教而放弃了那种方式，这就是为什么有那么多希腊的……所以如果他们那样做了，我们为什么要回去？希尔曼就像，呃，呃，我不知道。他没有答案。还没想通那个。嗯，我会……所以这本书在很大程度上是……某种程度上是对我关于我们一直在谈论的，人类心理觉醒历史的观点的阐述。但我还从设计的角度讨论了建造城市的过程。在其中，我基本上通过你在新城市主义大会、新城市主义宪章中会发现的设计元素，我进入了……实际上有一个关于金融的章节，我们如何为我们建造的地方融资。所以那句老话是什么？形式追随功能。而从开发商的角度来看，形式追随金融。所以我们现在面临的很多问题，就个人建筑和公共基础设施而言，都与我们融资的方式以及我们……
That was the one question he couldn't answer. There's a famous, I mean, you never see Hillman speechless. I mean, he never shut up. And somebody from Canada, I think professor said, you know, you keep saying that we need to go back to polytheism. We need to go back to Greek. I think if you let Hillman go, he would have gone back to the mother cult. I mean, he wanted to totally regress into the unconscious and i mean he would have kept going but the guy
仅仅因为资金流动的方式而无法做某些事情。而资金以特定的方式流动，是因为他们赋予它的价值。它本身就是一个目的，而不是一个工具。至于具体的设计元素，我所做的一件事是采取……所以我们现在面临的问题，全球变暖，气候变化，购物中心和办公园区的消亡，诸如此类。物理上有一个真正的转变。全国范围内，我们的零售业严重过剩。
said you keep talking about polytheism and the greeks and all this stuff why should we do that they abandoned that way for monotheism like greek the greeks gave all of that up to convert to christianity which is why there's so much greek of it. So why, if they did that, why should we go back? And Hillman's like, uh, uh, I don't know. He doesn't have an answer. Hadn't thought that one through yet. Um, what I would, so the book is in large part, uh, sort of an exposition of my perspective on what we've been talking about, the history
现在实体店正在消失，取而代之的是在线购物。所以我们有所有这些废弃的沃尔玛，我们正在把它们改建成大型教堂，还有所有这些废弃的带状购物中心，我们正在把它们改建成，你知道，电子烟店。对。是的。所以你拿那些东西怎么办？还有产权贷款商店。所以我几年前做了一个实验。我是宾夕法尼亚州兰开斯特市城市规划委员会的主席，他们镇上旁边的大型购物中心……最近……他们失去了大约60%的商店，
of human psychological awakening. But I also discuss the process of building a city from a design perspective. And in that, I basically through the um design elements that you'll find in uh the congress for new urbanism the charter of the new urbanism and i get into there's actually a chapter on finance um how we finance the places we build. So what's the old adage? Form follows function. And from a developer's perspective, form follows finance. And so a lot of issues that we have now as far as an individual building and public infrastructure have to do with the way we finance things and the way that
他们正在挣扎，就像全国成百上千的其他购物中心一样。所以我决定做一个小小的个人实验，使用类似于朗方的方法论，把这个曾经是160英亩的购物中心、200英亩的购物中心变成一个可步行的社区。嗯，所以我创造了那种潜在的格子，几何格子在房产上，嗯，从中长出了一个新传统社区的街道模式，嗯，这与旧历史城市的市中心相当。那个几何格子的点、线和角
we simply can't do certain things because of the way that the money flows. And the money flows in certain ways because of the value that they place on it. It's an end in itself rather than a tool. As far as the specific design elements, one of the things that I did was to take, so the issues that we're faced with now, global warming, climate change, the death of shopping malls and office parks, and so on and so forth. There's a real shift physically. Nationwide we are vastly over retailed.
构成了公园入口、儿童游乐场、图书馆、市政厅的位置。换句话说，它创造了一个类似于分散的公民公共空间网络，这样你从一个地方走到另一个地方，但你始终是社区的一部分。所以我是在圣公会长大的，不是天主教徒，但我们也像天主教徒一样，在教堂里有苦路，教堂内部……我也是在圣公会长大的。
And now brick and mortar stores are going away in favor of online shopping. So we have all these abandoned Walmarts we're converting into megachurches and all of these abandoned strip malls that we're converting into, you know, vape stores. Right. Yeah. So what do you do with that stuff? And title loan stores do. And so I conducted an experiment years ago. I was the chairman of the city planning commission in lancaster pennsylvania and their big shopping mall in town off to the side um more recently um they have lost something like 60 of their their stores
我们过去称它为“轻量级天主教”，因为……好的。我记得坚信礼课程就像是，它会像是，这是浸信会相信的，这是天主教徒相信的。我们并没有真正告诉你。你可以选择，你知道，一个新的。但是的，那个坚信礼并没有真正
and they're struggling just like hundreds of other malls across the country so I decided to do a little personal experiment and use something akin to LaFonce methodology to turn this what was 160 acre shopping mall 200 acre shopping mall into a walkable neighborhood. Uh, and so I created that sort of an underlying trellis, geometric trellis on the property, um, and out of that grew a street pattern of a new traditional neighborhood, um, that is comparable to the downtown of the old historic city. And the points and lines and angles of that geometric trellis
任何东西。所以在教堂内部，会有一系列艺术作品、雕像、绘画等等，描绘基督受难前生命最后几天的挂毯。所以它们就像这些小的学习站。所以也许这个想法是将那些苦路扩展到整个城市，这样在你可以穿过整个城市的路径上就有灵感和学习的点，所以这可能是连接
form the location of the entrance to a park, a children's playground, a library, a city hall. In other words, it creates a network of sort of like a dispersed civic commons so that you're walking from one place to another, but you're always a part of the community. So I was raised Episcopalian, not Catholic, but we also, like the Catholics, had the Stations of the Cross in a church where the interior of the church... I grew up Episcopalian, too.
从一个开放空间到另一个……市政结构，如市政厅或图书馆或学校，不管是什么，社区花园，并从主题上链接这些东西，这样它们一起讲述一个故事，并通过城市设计以及放置在那里的设计元素在你心中引发问题。所以朗方没能做到的一件事基本上是告诉人们他在做什么。所以不清楚这两个点
We used to call it Catholic light because... Okay. I remember a confirmation class was like, it'd be like, this is what Baptists believe, this is what Catholics believe. We don't really tell you. You can pick, you know, a new one. But yeah, there was nothing that confirmation of this wasn't really
国会大厦和白宫代表了更大的东西。我们有一些模糊的概念，但我认为我们现在需要的是清晰和具体的东西。也许一个好的总结是我们看看荣格作为建筑师会设计什么，因为他在博林根（Bollingen）投入了很多心思，而且他尽可能亲手建造了博林根。所以我们有点看到了他的建筑
anything. So in the interior of a church, there will be a series of works of art, statuary paintings and so forth, tapestries that depict the last days of Christ's life before the crucifixion. So they're like these little stations of learning. And so perhaps the idea is to expand those stations of the cross out throughout the entire city so that there are points of inspiration and learning on a path that you can create throughout the entire city so this might be connections
理想是什么。但如果荣格要建造一个城市，如果他要成为一名城市规划师，我是说，你认为他会怎么想？他会怎么布局那样的东西？他留下了一点那样的遗产。我想是在《红书》里，我想。它来自他的利物浦梦，对吧，他在那里梦到了城市中间岛屿上的树和灯柱。而且鉴于他的背景和历史等等，有一个非常美丽的渲染，它非常有中世纪的外观。如果你知道意大利军事城镇帕尔马诺瓦（Palmanova），形状像一颗星星，周围有护城河，那可能影响了荣格在他的利物浦梦中所做的，
from open space to another um civic structures like city hall or the library or the school, what have you, community garden, and link these things thematically so that together they tell a story and provoke in you questions through the urban design and also the elements of design that are placed in there. So one of the things that LaFont failed to do was basically tell people what he was doing. So it was not clear that these two points
类似那样的东西。所以有很多可能性在这些废弃的旧址上做很多不同的事情，比如购物中心等等。现有的城镇，我认为将是一个非常、非常困难的努力，将这个概念改造到现有的地方。我认为当我们查看海平面上升的地图时，这是必要的，例如。在未来的几十年里，纽约处于危险之中。我的家乡泰德沃特（Tidewater），弗吉尼亚州。他们在迈阿密建造任何东西。这对我来说太不真实了。
of the Capitol and the White House represented something larger. We have some vague notion, but what I think we need now is something clear and specific. Maybe a good wrap-up is we see what Jung would have designed as an architect because he put a lot of thought into Bollingen, and he built as much of Bollingen by hand as he could. So we kind of see what his architectural
迈阿密是……迈阿密有数百万美元的新建筑。几年内它就会被淹没。不，它们已经是了。你现在可以定期看到迈阿密海滩被六英寸水淹没的照片。所以所有那些人都必须搬到某个地方。我们开始看到卡特里娜飓风之后，新奥尔良的一半最终去了休斯顿。所以这些所谓的接收城市如何为难民的涌入做好准备？
ideal was. But if Jung was to build a city, if he was to be an urban planner, I mean, how do you think he would have thought? How would he have laid out something like that? He left a little bit of a legacy like that. I guess it's in the Red Book, I think. It came out of his Liverpool dream, right, where he had that dream of the tree and the lamppost on an island in the middle of the city. and there's a beautiful little rendition of that given his background and history and so forth that has a very much a medieval look. If you know the Italian military town, Palmanova shaped like a star with a moat around it that probably influenced what Young did with his Liverpool dream,
所以买中西部的房地产，你是这个意思吗？实际上，已经制作了一张地图，显示了最有可能能够接收新人口涌入的地区。我认为最安全的地方是像密歇根州中部那样的地方，诸如此类，那里没有洪水，没有飓风，没有龙卷风，温度也会还可以。所以社区，如果我们只是以某种恐慌模式应对这种环境危机，我们必须快速建造更多的东西，因为人们要来了。所以就像工程项目一样完成它。我们将创造未来的贫民窟。所以这种过渡必须深思熟虑地完成，而且我认为人类历史上第一次
something like that. So there are a lot of possibilities to do a lot of different things on these old abandoned sites like shopping malls and so forth. Existing towns, that's going to be a really, really much more difficult sort of effort, I think, to sort of retrofit this concept into existing places. I think it's necessary when we look at maps of sea level rise, for instance. In the coming decades, New York is at risk. My home area of Tidewater, Virginia. They're building anything in Miami. It's just so unreal to me.
有机会向前看，看到重大的全球变化即将到来，不仅是在环境上，而且在宇宙学上，我们思考自己和世界的方式正在改变，
Miami is... Millions of dollars of new construction in Miami. It's going to be too big underwater in years. No, they already are. You can see photographs of Miami Beach under six inches of water on a regular basis now. So all of those people are going to have to decant somewhere. And we're starting to see after Katrina, half of New Orleans ended up in Houston. So how do these sort of receiver cities prepare themselves for an influx of refugees?
我们有机会为之做好准备。我们思考自己和世界的方式正在改变。我们有机会为之做好准备。你有信心我们会吗？最终会，但我真的不认为……丘吉尔说美国人在尝试了所有其他方法后，总是会做正确的事情。而且我认为我们会拼命坚持现状，直到我们被迫改变我们的方式。所以，是的，这不会很漂亮。嗯，我真的很感谢你来参加。如果人们想买这本书，我很乐意。
So by real estate in the Midwest, is that what you're saying? Actually, there's been a map made of areas which are most likely to be able to receive an influx of new people. I think the safest place is something like the center of Michigan, something like that, where no floods, no hurricanes, no tornadoes, temperature is going to be okay. So communities, if we simply respond to this sort of environmental crisis in sort of a panic mode, we've got to build more stuff quickly because people are coming. So just get it done like an engineering project. We're going to be creating future slums. So this sort of transition has to be done thoughtfully and I think for the first time in history humanity has
你有什么偏好的方式吗？如果你直接买，你会赚更多钱吗？嗯，是的，我实际上……如果我亲手给你一本书，那是最好的，但大多数销售将通过亚马逊。你要做有声书版本吗？我的很多年轻人，30岁以下的所有人，他们都是那样消费他们所有的书的。有一个9.99美元的电子书。亚马逊上的纸质版，我想是35美元。巴诺书店和其他三四个渠道也有。
the opportunity to sort of look ahead and see major global changes coming not just environmentally but cosmologically the way we think about ourselves and the world is changing
有机会展望未来，预见重大的全球性变革，这不仅是在环境方面，更是在宇宙观层面，我们看待自身和世界的方式正在发生改变
and we have the opportunity to prepare for that The way we think about ourselves and the world is changing. We have the opportunity to prepare for that. Do you have faith that we will? Eventually, but I really don't think... Churchill said Americans will always do the right thing after they've tried everything else. And I think we will fight tooth and nail to hang on to the status quo until we're forced to change our ways. So, yeah, it won't be pretty. Well, I really appreciate you coming on. I would love if people want to buy the book.
我们有机会为此做好准备。我们看待自身和世界的方式正在改变，我们有机会为此做好准备。你相信我们能做到吗？最终会，但我真的不认为……丘吉尔曾说，美国人在尝试了所有其他方法后，总会做出正确的选择。我认为我们会拼尽全力维持现状，直到被迫改变。所以，是的，过程不会太美好。非常感谢你能来。如果人们想买这本书，我很高兴。
Is there a way that you prefer them to do that uh do you make more money if they buy it directly um yeah i i actually um if i hand you a book by hand it's uh it's best but uh most sales will be through amazon you're gonna do an audiobook version? So many of my younger people, just everybody under 30, that's how they consume all their books. There is an e-book for $9.99. The hard copy from Amazon is, I think, $35. Barnes & Noble and three or four other outlets as well.
你有什么偏好的购买方式吗？比如直接购买你会赚得更多吗？嗯，如果我亲手把书交给你，那是最好的，但大多数销售还是会通过亚马逊。你会出有声书版本吗？我很多年轻的读者，尤其是30岁以下的人，他们都是通过这种方式阅读的。电子书售价9.99美元，亚马逊上的纸质版我想是35美元，巴诺书店和其他三四家渠道也有售。
There's a lot of, most cities have like, or states have like a young society or whatever, and they do, you know, talks once a week or whatever. But they, Jungians like Jungian thought, you know, spilling into other areas. And that may be a good marketing thing if you make a... They'll email their group or let you come talk. I know there's one here. Atlanta's is a lot bigger than Birmingham's. You probably want to go to the bigger cities. Chicago's incredibly active too.
很多城市或州都有荣格协会之类的组织，他们每周都会举办讲座。荣格学派的人喜欢将荣格思想应用到其他领域。如果你能联系他们，让他们通过邮件通知会员或者邀请你去演讲，这可能是一种很好的营销方式。我知道这里有一个，亚特兰大的规模比伯明翰的大得多。你可能更想去大城市，芝加哥的活动也非常活跃。
Chicago, very definitely. I did give a lecture at the Young Society here in Washington two years ago, I think, and met James Hollis through that process, and fabulous guy, yeah, so yeah, I'm wide open for, in fact, I've got one lecture to my professional New urbanist group here in town and looking for more. Well, great. That sounds wonderful. Well, good luck to you. And is there anything that you'd
芝加哥确实非常活跃。我想两年前我在华盛顿的荣格协会做过一次演讲，并通过那个过程认识了詹姆斯·霍利斯，他是个很棒的人。所以，我非常乐意去演讲。事实上，我已经在城里的专业新城市主义小组做过一次演讲，并期待更多机会。太好了，听起来很棒。祝你好运。还有什么你想补充的吗？或者我们可以查看的网站，除了在亚马逊上买书之外，还有什么能帮到你的吗？
like to add or a website we can check out, anything that helps you other than people getting a book on Amazon? Well, I am in the process of starting a nonprofit and an associated website, the Institute for Symbolic Urbanism. Okay. And that is in process, and it will be basically the ground on which I will try to refine some of these ideas into something workable for the future. If you have an interest in young and place, psychological growth and urbanism, it would be great to be able to put the two together into sort of a new way of thinking about and doing urbanism. You didn't want to go for the new, new urbanism, the Congress for the new, new urbanism?
我正在筹建一个非营利组织和一个相关的网站，叫“象征性城市主义研究所”（Institute for Symbolic Urbanism）。好的，这正在进行中，它将成为我尝试将这些想法提炼成未来可行方案的基础。如果你对荣格、场所、心理成长和城市主义感兴趣，能将两者结合起来，形成一种思考和实践城市主义的新方式将会很棒。你不想去参加“新城市主义大会”吗？
A friend of mine, Kevin Klinkenberg, has a really great podcast where he's questioning the viability of the Congress for New Urbanism. It may be spreading out into other groups. There's the Strong Towns Movement, all those. I don't think they all agree on the philosophy anymore like they did in the beginning. It's starting to have new hypotheses about what the best path forward is. Well, that's kind of a good thing. After COVID and what's happened with downtown office space, for instance, there's a lot of rethinking that has to be done. New urbanism started out
我的朋友凯文·克林肯伯格有一个很棒的播客，他在质疑“新城市主义大会”的可行性。它可能正在分散到其他群体中，比如“强大城镇运动”等等。我不认为他们现在还像最初那样在哲学上达成一致。关于未来最好的路径，人们开始有了新的假设。嗯，这其实是件好事。例如，在新冠疫情之后，随着市中心办公空间的变化，有很多反思需要进行。新城市主义最初是作为一种改善郊区的方式开始的，
as a way of doing better suburbia. Maybe that's that has been rethought quite a bit. And it may not need to be the focus anymore. Well, that makes sense. I appreciate your time.
也许这一点已经被重新思考了很多。它可能不再需要成为焦点了。嗯，这很有道理。感谢你抽出时间。
And I guess, do you have the name of the website? Can you say that? I think it's just isu.org. Okay just ISU.org. Okay. ISU.org. Oh,
我想问一下，网站的名字是什么？你能说一下吗？我想应该是 isu.org。好的，就是 ISU.org。好的，ISU.org。哦，
I'm sorry. Um, symbolic urbanism.org. Okay. Symbolic urbanism.org. Yeah. And it'll be up in, Oh Lord,
抱歉，是 symbolicurbanism.org。好的，symbolicurbanism.org。是的，它大概会在，天哪，
maybe six weeks, September. Okay. You want us to hold the episode until it's live or go ahead and put it, put it out. Um, you can hold it for a couple of weeks. That would be fine. Well, it's totally up to you. Whatever's more helpful. I'd enough. You want us to hold the episode until it's live or go ahead and put it out? You can hold it for a couple of weeks. That would be fine.
也许六周后，九月份上线。好的。你是希望我们等到网站上线再发布这一集，还是直接发布？你可以等几周，没关系。这完全取决于你，怎样对你更有帮助。你希望我们等到网站上线再发布这一集，还是直接发布？你可以等几周，没关系。
Well, it's totally up to you. Whatever is more helpful and if the book's for sale, you know, sometimes the Amazon algorithm likes more. If you have more out the gate, then it keeps it up there longer. Yeah, you know what? Go ahead and do it as you will. No need to wait. Because I'm actually going to bring in some professional help. What I've done so far on the website is kind of amateurish.
这完全取决于你，怎样对你更有帮助。如果书已经在售，亚马逊的算法有时会更青睐那些刚发布时就有更多流量的作品，这样能让它在榜单上停留更久。好吧，随你们便吧，不用等了。因为我实际上打算找专业人士帮忙，目前我做的网站还有点业余。
So it might be a couple more months than I anticipate. So go ahead. Okay. Yeah, we'll have you go ahead and get that live. And thank you for sitting down with us. I'm going to go ahead and stop the recording. And be sure and check out Will's website and other projects as they come available. It's glass and concrete and stone It is just a house
所以可能比我预期的要晚几个月，所以你们直接发布吧。好的，那我们就直接发布了。感谢你接受我们的采访。我要停止录音了。请务必关注威尔的网站和其他即将推出的项目。它是玻璃、混凝土和石头，它只是房子，
not a home There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而不是家。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。